Do you have any goal at all of growing as a human being,
of being a better person?
Is that at all a goal for you,
and feeling comfortable within your own self and not feeling
you have to constantly prove something?
We often find there are a lot
of grandiose narcissistic dreams and goals
we had at one point, which we just totally
don't have anymore because we've done inner work.
So these kinds of questions are help starting from within
as opposed to from, without.
Hey people. There you are welcome to the podcast.
Today, we're gonna explore the psychology
of self-actualization and transcendence,
and we're gonna do it with Scott Barry Kaufman.
Scott is a cognitive scientist and humanistic psychologist
who was taught at Columbia, Yale, NYU, Penn and elsewhere.
He received his PhD in cognitive psychology from Yale,
a masters in experimental psychology from Cambridge
and a bachelors in psychology and human computer interaction
from Carnegie Mellon.
Currently, Scott is the founder and director
of the Center for the Science of Human Potential.
He hosts the number one psychology podcast in the world,
"The Psychology Podcast"
and in 2015 was named by "Business Insider" as one
of 50 groundbreaking scientists who are changing
the way we see the world.
In addition to writing for "The Atlantic",
"Scientific American", "Psychology Today"
and "Harvard Business Review",
Scott is the author and editor of nine books.
The latest of which is entitled, "Transcend the new science
of self-actualization" and that book forms the basis
for today's discussion about how and what it means
to pursue a transcendent life.
I found Scott to be really engaging, fun, frank, vulnerable.
I really enjoy talking to him so this is me
and Dr. Scott Barry Kaufman coming at you in three,
two, one, go.
Cool man, well Scott, I'm so happy to meet you.
This has been a long time coming.
Yeah, it really has. And it's a real real honor for me.
It's an honor for me.
There's so many things that I want to talk to you about.
You have written extensively on subject matter that is dear
to me, personally that I'm excited to explore
with you today.
Of course, self-actualization and transcendence,
which you explore beautifully by extension of the work
of Abraham Maslow, who we were just chatting
about before the podcast and how meaningful he's been
in your life by dent of this fantastic book that you've put
out recently, "Transcend".
But prefatory to that, I think it
would be really interesting and also to help kind
of contextualize your background a little bit to talk
about being a late bloomer.
Oh wow.
'Cause that's something that I'm familiar with.
We have different versions of late bloomer stories,
but I think your story and the work that you've done
around late bloomers kind of helped set the stage
for talking about these other things.
Yeah, sure. I'm really interested in potential
and studied things from prodigy.
These kids who really start really, really young
and like how the heck they able to play a complete piano,
like without ever taking any lessons to (indistinct)
to all sorts of things.
And so there's different ways of thinking
about late bloomers.
In my specific case, I was in special education,
very young 'cause I was essentially deaf
the first three years of my life.
Made it very hard for me to process things in real time.
And teacher took that as an indication that I was stupid,
not just teachers, but like bullies and everyone.
Well, everyone and my mom believed in me though,
my parents believed in me.
That's important.
Yeah. That is super important.
So I repeated third grade,
so a late boom in that sense as well.
So I was delayed there and I was kept in special education
with, it's a very heterogeneous group in special education.
So I was with problem kids like the most acting
out kids in the school so that they would like bully me
in special ed and it's like, why did you put me.
Yeah.
With my bullies in the same room? Thank you.
Thank you school.
But to autism spec, there's such a wide range of people
that were put into there.
And I was kept there all the way till ninth grade,
but always did feel as though I was capable of more.
I really was confused that on the one hand,
the way I was kind of treated by the school.
But on the other hand, I knew my inner life,
had a rich inner life.
I just loved fantasy and imagination.
And I would like act out like soap opera plot lines
in my head where I was like the leading man.
And I would like be to be continued every day.
And then the next day I would pick up in my head,
it's all in my head, I would like write stories
and novels and things.
So there was really this duality within me
that was really frustrating and confusing
because I was those like, whoa, can I question
the authorities at all?
Like they, everyone thinks I'm dumb,
but I do feel like there is greater potential within me.
And it really, it really took,
feel free to stop me at any time. But.
Yeah, no, no, no.
I mean, at some point you have this teacher in ninth grade
who believes in you and that becomes kind of a lever
for you to break out of this paradigm.
But what I find interesting about this and I haven't heard
you talk about is what the origin of that belief in self
that persisted despite all this kind of external input
that was trying to tell you
that there was something wrong with you.
I try to, I think about that a lot.
I've had some great conversations with like Angela Duckworth
who wrote a phenomenal book called, "Grit" about this
because my office was right next door to hers
when I was at Penn.
Oh wow.
I was running the Imagination Institute
while she was running the character lab.
So we were like, oh, we should like team up and like,
see what the conjunction of imagination and grit
would be sort of thing.
But we would have lots of like walk home,
the talks as we would walk home from after a long day
of work, try to just understand what was
that was really going on with me in my personal life.
I think grit is a big part of the story.
I think I'd be remiss not to say there was this confluence
of passion and perseverance within me.
And it's the confluence of the two that I think
is really important.
Any one without the other is, if you just have perseverance
without passion that's just like duty,
if you just have passion without perseverance, what is that?
That's just excitement.
Right. But then the question becomes,
are those inbred traits that you just had coming out
of the womb or was there something about the resistance
that you were meeting in your world that emboldened them
or strengthened them?
Yeah. I think that it got unlocked to use
a bad scientific metaphor.
It's not like a key that gets unlocked but there was a point
in my life where this special ed teacher took me aside
in ninth grade after class.
And she asked me, what are you still doing here?
She was the first one to really
just even ask me that question.
We talk like in the coaching world,
we talk about powerful questions, right?
Questions that really cause you
to have huge self-transformation.
Well, talk about a powerful question in my life,
this woman, all she asked me, she's like,
what are you still doing here in special ed?
And I thought to myself, what am I still doing?
Process to what she said?
And I said, yeah,
what the fuck am I still doing here?
And something really got unleashed in me.
Like in that moment, something I had been building up
for many, many years.
That's almost like I just needed some catalyst or someone
to just even questioned that I maybe I had more potential.
And I just like from there, like it was wildfire.
Like I just, I called my mom.
I ran to the payphone and called my mom and I said,
hey, I'm not going to special ed anymore.
She's like screaming. She's like,
what did they do to you there?
But I set up a meeting with the school psychologist,
the administrators, the special ed teachers
and they had nothing in the rule books of our school system
for that to be the case for a special ed student
to break out by themselves.
So you had to like litigate this.
It was the first time, they had nothing.
They were like looking through
what do we do with this situation?
And so what they decided on is they were gonna let me out on
a trial basis.
So I was like, thanks for the vote of confidence guys.
They said, we're gonna let you out.
You can take mainstream classes, even
I know you wanna take honors classes, fine.
We'll let you take some honors classes, but if you fail,
you're coming right back in.
But in that moment, I will tell you, my attitude was,
oh, I'm gonna prove them.
Yeah.
Like I think a big part of my 20's and from high school,
from that point up to maybe the end of my 20's
was really driven by the underdog motivation,
which is a phenomenon I'm really fascinated about.
And I read about and I'm actually working an article,
a bigger article about it right now, but I think it's huge.
Yeah I mean, I can certainly relate to that.
I was wondering, as you're telling that story,
then looking at all of these higher degrees
that you've accumulated and you just,
you publish with (indistinct).
You're very prolific in your writing.
How much of that is motivated?
How much of your motivation can be tracked back
to still trying to prove those kids wrong,
in that classroom?
Yeah. A big part of it.
Another part of it's I really discovered I loved learning
and I felt like I had a lot to catch up on.
There was a real feeling of well, okay.
Here's the deal, at that point when I got out, I was like,
okay, Scott, here's the deal.
You're not college-bound right now.
What is it gonna have to take for a college
to even look at you?
I mean, I had to think about this situation.
I was in ninth grade.
I was, I got out of special ed.
I was not on a college track.
And so I was like, I'm gonna do this.
And in order to do something like that,
I had to pull all the stops.
I signed up for everything, as my course like coded
for the summer school classes to like catch up.
I signed up for like honors classes
and I was in remedial classes.
So I didn't even wanna take standard.
I was like, let's just go, let's just go for it.
Wow.
So I signed up for like honors Latin and ended up being
a Latin scholar.
I ended up like, I mean,
I wasn't good at everything.
Like I tried a lot of things that like "Le Mis"
that I tried like, not "Le Mis"
but like "West Side Story".
I was like, I can't do this dancing.
I dropped out of "West Side Story" in community theater.
But you tried.
I did try. I did sign up for like everything.
And I was like, I'm going all in on this.
And I just had this voracious passion to learn as well.
I mean, I think part of the story is also
to prove people wrong,
but I think there was all also like
that's not a sustainable motivation by itself. Right.
I think when you pair that, that kind of passion,
passion to prove people wrong. Is that still a passion?
That's a passion,
but I combined it with a real love of learning
and just voraciously wanting to catch up.
I felt I was so behind.
I just wanted to catch up.
So you go on to basically pursue
this very successful career.
And looking back in retrospect, it's helped form
these interesting ideas that you have about education.
You've got this manifesto on your website about change,
kind of altering the paradigm of education is something
that I think a lot about as a parent of a bunch of kids
and seeing what they go through and how it could be better.
And also just this idea of what it means to be
a late bloomer and how we judge people too quickly early
in their development that has damaging implications
for how they think about themselves
and ultimately pursue their lives in the world.
Yeah. Yeah.
I think we have it all wrong
about what the markers of potential are,
especially in a K through 12 system.
This notion that it's okay, the kids there, we got to get,
make sure they're getting perfect SAT scores.
We have to make sure they're getting into the right college.
That's going the wrong direction.
Basically what you're saying is we need to find the kids
who are really good at conformity.
We need to find the kids that aren't in detention.
I mean, we've really got it backwards.
Yeah. It's comp completely backwards.
It's reminiscent a little bit
of David Epstein's book, "Range".
I love him.
Which I talk about all the time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe your ideas and his ideas kind of overlap.
And that diagram, the idea of trying to instill
in young people, curiosity and at least enough gumption,
or courage to try lots of different things and kind
of hold them lightly so that you're like yourself,
like trying lots of stuff as a young person that all ends up
kind of congealing in the soup of creating a person
who becomes, ultimately, if they are embracing
this hierarchical model of meeting their needs,
creates a situation in which they're perfectly suited
for what they end up doing in the world.
And that's self-actualization.
Yeah.
That's a really good, quick definition of what Maslow
and myself meant by self-actualization.
Yeah. So let's talk about that.
Self-actualization, transcendence, my favorite subjects.
Maslow's hierarchy of needs
which most people are familiar with.
So why don't we start with kind of defining our terms
before we launch into this because you have
Good idea.
You have definitions of these things that I think
are different from what people might expect.
Absolutely. So Abraham Maslow's a humanistic psychologist,
one of the founders of the field of humanistic psychology.
Beginning of '50s, '60s had this notion
of self-actualization.
Earlier on in his career, he viewed self-actualization
as becoming all that you're capable, becoming uniquely,
like what is your creative potential?
What is your highest creative potential?
You can differentiate that from the lower needs
that we have, which are needs we share in common
with other people.
So we all have the needs for safety,
the needs for connection to a certain degree.
We don't like loneliness for instance, need for respect,
a need to a certain degree, a need for self-esteem.
These are things we all share with others.
They don't make you particularly unique by saying, oh,
I really want friends, but if you can play violin concerto,
like no one else in the world can play it, okay.
Now we're talking, there's something really unique
or you can do anything like that really gets to the core
of your own unique being.
Then we start to talk about self-actualization,
but I wanna say there was like a pre-phase in Maslow
and a later phase which is what I've been trying to kind
of carry the baton in a certain way to make clear
that towards the end of his life,
especially after he had his heart attack and he survived
the heart attack, his whole world view changed
and it changed quite dramatically.
And he started to see self-actualization
a little bit differently than he used to see it.
He started to see it really as just a bridge
to transcendence.
He says, at one point he says, well, it seems like
the function of self-actualization is actually
to erase itself.
So when done right, we self-actualize
our unique creative potentials in such a way
where are giving it out to the world where our being is
so in synchrony with the world and it's synergy is the word,
synergy with the world that what is automatically good
for me is good for others.
That my being and the things I'm doing in the world,
like your podcast, you love doing your podcast,
but it's so much in synergy with
what other people wanna hear,
you're really helping the world by doing something you love.
Does it feel like you're self-actualizing every day
or are you transcending?
I would argue you're more transcending.
So the idea being that self-actualization is aligned
with a more individualistic pursuit
of self betterment, right.
It's focused on the self, whereas transcendence,
which is an outgrowth of self-actualization becomes more
outward looking in terms of like what you're contributing
to the betterment of humanity.
Yeah.
Or aligning the actions or your behavior that are
the result of self-actualization with that mission
of global betterment or the betterment of humanity.
Is that accurate?
Yes. And I wanna be clear that I don't necessarily mean
like your life is a failure if it hasn't happened
in some hugely like economically impactful way
or like a quantitative way that the goal is always
to help a billion people on the planet
or help a million people have huge businesses.
I think there are people who do in quieter ways.
I talk a little about the slight triad.
I don't know if we wanna like double click that
but there's a certain way of being
that I think is underappreciated.
And I think that get back to the world in beautiful ways
every day I mean, you can have someone who has a company,
runs a company and is bragging about how many people
they're impacting, but they're an asshole to people
in their life every single day of their lives.
Well, that counts too.
I'm sorry. That counts.
I think a lot of my work is really about being more
than doing, and I think doing is very important.
Don't get me wrong.
I think like actually changing the world.
But I think we underestimate the extent
to which you're being can change the world.
If that makes sense.
The Maslow's hierarchy of needs is commonly understood
as this pyramid and I want to talk about
how that's not the case and you have this sailboat analogy
that much better kind of encapsulates
what he was getting at.
But I am interested, I do wanna spend a little time on
that difference between doing and being, right
because that pyramid paradigm sort of connotes like
an active verb relationship with these needs.
You're working your way through all of these things
in lockstep whereas being is more of a letting go
and allowing process, which is ephemeral.
And I think difficult to kind of wrap our brains
around how that actually operates.
So the distinction between being and doing, yeah?
Well, I'm also a personality psychologist.
So a lot of being is just a fancy spiritual way
of saying personality.
What are our patterns of behaviors
that have maybe become habits to a certain degree that we,
they become so ingrained in us that there
are like automatic reflexes now
when we encounter certain things.
So when for instance when I wrote my book,
"Wired to Create", a lot of that book was
about how to have creativity as part of your being.
Now that doesn't mean you're not doing things in the world.
It means that you have certain habits of mind
and certain habits of ways of acting and responding
to the world that consistently moves you in the direction
of greater creativity.
Like openness to experience is a way of being.
That phrase by the way,
a way of being was big among the humanistic psychologists.
But it's not a phrase that many people use these days
and you don't see many biohackers.
Right.
The term, way of being, when they're selling
their products, they're like,
we'll improve your performance but they're not like,
we'll improve your way of being but I think it should,
it should be part of it, for sure.
Yeah. So a lot of it,
I'm talking about personality structure,
I'm talking about worldviews, ways of processing the world
and ways of being in the world and interaction
and in relation to others.
So let's get to the hierarchy specifically
and the differences between what we understand commonly
as a pyramid versus like this sailboat version
of understanding it.
Yeah. So many people are probably familiar
with Maslow's hierarchy of needs is depicted as a pyramid.
Have you seen the?
Sure, yeah.
Everyone's seen the pyramid.
Do you have one of those things where you can like put
in the interview, like a picture of something.
We could find that.
So at the bottom you have like the basic need
of like safety and then belonging above that.
And self-esteem above that.
And then self-actualization above that as though life
is some sort of linear sort of trek up some mountain
or something and you reach some basic level
of a certain need, like need for connection.
And then there's some voice from above like, congrats,
you've evoked self-esteem or family.
Right, moving onto the next stage
of the video game, level.
Yeah. Well, first of all, Maslow never drew a pyramid
in any of his writing as I'm going through.
And trust me, I think I read like everything
he's ever written, including his like 2000-page,
two volume journal, personal journals,
he never drew a pyramid.
So I was like, where's the pyramid?
And he never thought about life as a video game either.
So that's a misunderstanding of his theory of motivation.
It's much better to think of life as a two-step forward,
one-step back dynamic.
We have to choose the growth option over and over again
and consciously make those choices
but there's lots of forces, subconscious forces within us,
as well as lots of forces outside of us
that we can't control.
And work also plays a big factor in this that is pulling us
in directions that are not for our full growth.
So I thought a sailboat would be a better metaphor
for that kind of way of life.
So the thing with the sailboat metaphor is what's important
is the integration of the whole unit.
First of all, is it's not,
you're not like climbing up mountain.
It's like, how do all the parts
of the sailboat work together?
And are they harmoniously working together?
Are you fighting this like civil war
with inside yourself?
That's a phrase Maslow used, does it feel like
you're constantly like wanting to do this,
but then some, another side is pulling
you another direction.
But also with an integrated sailboat metaphor,
you have the boat it's self, which represents the needs.
The basic needs. If you have too many holes in the boat,
you're not going anywhere, right?
You're gonna be focusing all your energies on getting
the water the heck out of the boat, right?
It's similarly, if you're hungry, right?
You're not able to focus on much else.
If you're really chronically hungry, if you're lonely,
we know how much that affects your whole cognition,
your ability to self-actualize, if you're very,
very low and you feel like everything you do,
you're not getting respect. Right.
And that's not just narcissists who want respect,
by the way, it's a really fundamental human motive.
I think we overuse the term narcissist these days,
by the way, like everyone's a narcissist, except you.
Right? It's like everyone.
Oh, my ex-husband he's an narcissist or oh,
that my boss and it's like, we don't work within
but I think the person who is chronically lacking
the ability to enact their plans in life over
and over again, that creates a toll.
And that's a really human thing.
If you're really constantly coming up against those walls
to focus all your energies on that.
But again, that's gonna get in the way of your growth.
So that's the boat,
but eventually if you can get to a certain level, not level,
I shouldn't even use the word level, but you get to
in your life, you get to a place where there really
aren't these significant holes in your boat
and you really feel, you can move, you're moving,
you eventually need to open up that sail.
And they opening up the sail,
that's where the growth happens.
Because once you open up that sail,
you're gonna be vulnerable to the winds, to the waves.
There's a vast unknown of the sea.
The waves can come crashing down in all of us at once.
And then we we're, like, we thought we were going
in our own direction and then we realize we're all
in the sea together.
Or we thought we're going in a direction and then we'll have
to change direction like so many of us had
to do with COVID. Right.
But opening up that sail,
that's where the growth happens.
Yeah. What I like about that is it acknowledges all
of the many things over which we have no control.
Yeah.
That at any moment could capsize us, right?
And put us back at the very bottom of that hierarchy.
But at the same time,
there's kind of an elevated notion here as well.
Because when you raise the sail,
if the seas are calm and the wind is blowing
in your direction, you actually don't have to do anything.
The wind carries you, right.
There's this kind of invisible, spiritual alignment
when you are self-actualizing in the manner
in which you are designed to where, and I say this all
the time, like the universe will conspire to support you
in mysterious ways.
And that can all go terribly wrong an hour later
but there are those heightened moments that I've experienced
in my life and I love that the analogy kind
of contemplates that.
For sure. And those are transcend,
I would call those transcendent moments.
Or I'm sure you've, you know a lot about the flow state
in your personal life.
You certainly know a lot about the flow state.
And that is just such a feel magical.
Yeah.
You get in the flow state with humans,
fellow humans too, right.
Like you do all the time on your podcast.
Yeah. For sure.
Yeah.
Or you finish and you're like, well, that was three hours.
And they're like, what?
Yeah. Exactly. Exactly.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I always aspire to achieve that.
Yeah.
But I look at this as a mental model for making sense
of the world and a means by which to take control over
of how you're thinking about how you're pursuing
your life and I can't help but think of it in comparison
to 12-step, which is a model that is kind of like
a default mode in my mind for how I try
to understand the world.
Yeah.
And there are kind of active things that you do
within 12-step, the amends and the daily inventory
and spiritual practices.
But there's also this notion of acceptance and surrender.
And when you are talking about Maslow's heart attack,
what was interesting about that was that you would think
that that would put him lower on the hierarchy
because suddenly his security is being threatened
because he's being confronted with his mortality.
And yet it has the opposite impact on him,
which he found sort of interesting
and confusing at the time.
But what I see in that is kind of abrasive of these things
that we don't have control over that allow us to reach
a higher state of appreciation and gratitude and presence.
Absolutely but there's also like a whole paradox
that we can go down this whole rabbit hole
which is really a big mystery I try to solve in my book
and that's this, how come there are some people
when they experience these moments
of near death experiences in a (indistinct) for threats
to their mortality, they feel transcendence like Maslow did,
but there are those that have this mortality salience all
the time and they're constantly stuck
in the deficiency realm of human existence?
So that was a big question I tried to resolve and I only got
to it in the last chapter.
And so I don't know if you want me to spoil or like,
I had to get sort through a lot of the literature to get
to this, to explain this and to understand.
No, I wanna hear it.
Okay. I'll just go into it.
But just for people.
I mean, it's not like a thriller or it's like,
how's it gonna end? Yeah.
I wrote it kind of like a thriller.
It is a story. But as I said to you before the podcast,
it's a love letter also.
It is, yeah, for sure.
The way I resolved it, 'cause one in one way,
I do want people to read the book and like for things
to build on each other, like really bit by bit.
But I think that what I realized after sorting through all
this literature is that there's certain privilege
that Maslow had by having near death experience,
but having his security needs met when he that.
And I think that's key to being able
to experience transcendence because there are people
who live under really impoverished conditions
where every day of their life, they don't know
if they're gonna survive and it's not like
they are experiencing transcendence every day. Right.
They really are focused their attention on surviving.
So I think it's one of those things
where if you can harmoniously integrate lots of
these lower needs in your life and satisfy them
at a certain degree,
they're no longer part of your consciousness.
And you can have a near death experience.
You really can have some of the highest heights
of transcendence imaginable,
but I don't think that it's necessarily
the case for everyone and so a big part of what I tried
to this book as well is to understand
what are the conditions upon which we really can have some
of the most magical states of consciousness in the world,
but I'd be remiss if I didn't really point out that,
that isn't the case for everyone and not everyone even
has that opportunity for experiencing those highest height
of transcendence.
Prophets walk among us as.
A writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever that our world
is populated by scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share.
Those that we don't know who can and teach us something new
and leave us all the better
for the experience of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career to tracking down
the most compelling prophets on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and to sharing
the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium by which to share
their stories, which is why I'm proud to announce
the release of my new book,
"Voicing Change Volume II", more than mere words on paper.
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration and timeless wisdom that transpires each week
on "The Rich Roll Podcast".
The first edition of "Voicing Change"
was a beautifully rendered book worthy of display
on any coffee table and volume II follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication replete
with interview excerpts, essays and stunning photography,
making for an exquisite companion
to the first volume or a satisfying standalone work.
And every copy comes with a chance of winning
our golden ticket sweep stakes.
Six golden tickets will be hidden within a handful of books
and will unlock a treasure chest of cool gifts donated
by several of our sponsors.
See official rules for details.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday prophets and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained with it.
"Voicing Change Volume II" available now while supplies last
for a limited time.
Order your copy today only at richroll.com.
Let's walk through just the process of self-actualization
as you understand it.
I think everybody wants to self-actualize,
but I don't know that people have the necessary tools
to understand what that framework is and a methodology
for approaching their life in a kind of conscious
and intentional way to achieve that.
That is a great practical question.
That is like really important.
This aligns with a I'm trying start a form of coaching
and calling self-actualization coaching
where the purpose of the coaching process to help
the client find a life that works best for them.
Find a life that is not something they feel like they need
to or they should be a certain way
because of societal pressures
because if everyone's telling them to do certain thing,
but really getting in touch with these potentialities
within you that which when realize,
make you feel most alive in life,
make you feel most aspired, make you feel just a great,
great sense of calling or purpose.
So as far as I'm concerned,
living a self-actualized life is a constant direction,
but it's not a designation you ever achieve.
Same with transcendence.
That would suck if like it was a destination you get there,
then what do you do the moment after you transcend it?
It's like, what do I do with the rest of my life? Right.
Well, there's that adage before enlightenment,
chop wood, carry water, after enlightenment chop wood,
carry water.
Exactly. Exactly.
So it's a constantly process like choosing growth,
but what does it mean to choose growth?
What do I mean by choosing growth?
I mean, what does it mean to choose the option
that is moving you in directions that you really truly want
to move in?
But also it's a whole process of getting in touch with,
well, what is that?
What are those most alive centers of yourself?
Because I think there's lots of internal forces that pull
you away from that.
Of course they're external forces,
but I'm actually really to extent more interested
in the internal forces.
There are so many ways we hold ourselves back.
We don't even realize it in throughout the course
of our lives and like self-destructive things we do.
And so much of like choosing the growth,
it's not just so easy.
Just choose the growth option. You'll be fine.
No, there's so many parts of ourselves that don't want us
to choose the growth option.
Again, it could come down like guilt or shame.
Shame's a big one. Shame is such a big one.
How to live a real, fully actualized life.
So much of us have even a fear of succeeding.
It's called, Maslow called it the Jonah complex,
the fear of growth.
A lot of people have that.
A lot of people don't, they really want to do great things,
but they are very scared of what would happen if they're put
a position to do it.
What if they suddenly had that microphone?
What at all these people listening and suddenly
that's when all the trolls come running, they come running.
And so there's lots of aspects
of the self-actualization process that can be worked on.
I think like there should exist a coaching program that is
along those lines.
Yeah. A hundred percent.
I mean, I feel like that should be built
into young people's curriculum.
Yes.
As a means of better understanding themselves,
how can we make better decisions about what we wanna do
if we're completely, I think disconnection
from self is epidemic.
Most people are disconnected from self.
They don't understand what their impulses are telling them.
They have low self-worth.
The external forces distract us from ourself, right.
But then we have all these internal mechanisms,
as you mentioned, like I'm not worthy
or I don't deserve that.
Or I'm just trying to pay the bills or you don't understand
how difficult my life is,
all these barriers and obstacles that we erect
that insolate us from feeling compelled to do
that internal excavation to kind of parse what makes
you tick and what it is that makes you wake up in
the morning and get excited about anything
like the common thing that I'm sure you hear all the time is
I don't know what my passion is.
I don't know what's my purpose.
How do you begin to unpack that in an individual
so that they can start making tiny actions in the direction
of exploring that.
Yeah. I very much view it from like a Viktor Frankl lens
of it's more about calling than purpose.
The thing with purpose it sounds like something so internal
like I gotta find.
Or grandiose.
I gotta find that thing that I can only I can,
well, actually if you listen and talk to people
and just open your eyes you'll see there are
a billion callings all around you that you could pick.
Just pick one.
What I say to my students when I was teaching at Columbia,
just because students all the time will say like,
how do I know what my purpose is? It's like, calm down.
First of all, you're 20 years old.
You're 20 years old.
Right. But it's not their fault because all
of the external forces are telling them
that they need to have.
I agree.
An understanding of their life at that age.
I agree. But it's also heartbreaking when you see
how stress they are that they haven't found
their purpose yet. It's like, first of all, calm down,
there's 50-year-olds that still are freaking out.
They don't have found that purpose.
Like, but the thing is, there are so many things
that you can just pick, like look outside of yourself to
what are needs that are being unmet in others.
It's not all about your own unmet needs.
It's what are the unmet needs of others
that you can help fulfill?
And that only you, that you have like a unique skillset
to do so and does make you feel like you come alive.
Certainly I'm not suggesting that you pick anything,
but there are so many callings that potential callings,
if you're really truly listening,
if you're really truly getting outside yourself,
if you're, just read the news.
Read the news, you could help just give some aid
to people right now in the Ukraine,
like that's could be your calling and that's all I mean
by purpose, I think we put way too much pressure
on people to find the purpose within themselves
and far less pressure to be able to find a purpose outside
of yourself that you can contribute to.
Well, an important distinction there
is this difference between finding your purpose
in this self-serving manner, right?
Like that is responsive to our culture,
which is accumulate materialism.
Like how can I get mine and power and money
and luxury and comfort and all of that versus
this service component, which is a true driver of happiness,
right but is counterintuitive to the Western mindset,
which is looking to gird their own loins and not looking out
from a perspective of how can I contribute.
Maslow had this phrase he called dichotomy transcendence,
I love it.
I'm trying to bring it back.
Dichotomy transcendence.
Yeah. I say, bring it back.
It's not like it was ever part of the societal lexicon.
But it had a, well, it had a moment.
I know. So I'm saying.
Like 1966.
I don't think it ever did.
Even that, there's so many nerdy things
in Maslow's regs that only a true nerd
like myself truly appreciate.
But dichotomy transcendence is something I think
so important in the world right now.
And what that is, is we put so many things as opposites
of each other.
We're seeing it in the political warfares, we're seeing
in religious.
But we do in other ways, just like male, female, evil,
good, selfish, unselfish.
I wanted to encourage people to think about the fact
that there are lots of parts of humanity,
that there's a larger hole that we can actually rise above
and go to a higher state of consciousness where we view all
these things more objectively.
I don't think anything is good or bad by itself.
Aggression can be integrated in a really beautiful way
to help you change the world for the good, right?
Like it's not like not gonna curb your aggression, right?
No, it's about the integration.
So the reason why I bring this up with what you just said is
I actually don't like to think of the word selfishness
as bad, necessary bad.
And I wrote a paper, a scientific paper
where I created two scales to really investigate
this scientifically where I made the case that
we need a construct called healthy selfishness
and we need to do more research on pathological altruism.
And so the title of my paper was two forms
of paradoxical selfishness 'cause I wanted the field to kind
of look at this in a different way.
And I created this scale and I found out that paradoxically,
the more you have a healthy form of selfishness,
where you take care of yourself,
what you're doing in your life.
Yeah. It's benefiting you.
But it also just happens to benefit others at the same time,
just spontaneously, but the people who have higher are forms
of healthy selfishness actually have paradoxically
have higher genuine motives for helping others,
real, genuine motives for helping others.
They love to see other people grow.
They love to see other people succeed.
It's not all about themselves,
even though they scored higher on this selfish,
some of these kinds of items can be viewed selfish,
but they're really a healthy forms of selfishness.
Vice versa, I think we kind of act in our society
like there's so much pressure, like give, give,
give all the time.
There's all this pressure to like sacrifice yourself.
And I call BS on that.
And I think it's problematic when we live in a culture where
there's too much pressure to sacrifice yourself.
That could lead to all sorts of really
like significant psychopathologies.
You find people that score high
on our pathological altruism scale,
like have items like I need to be needed.
Like I help all the time, like 24/7 helping people.
And I'm such a good person I'm helping.
And we found that scale was correlated with depression.
That scale was correlated with narcissism.
That's the paradoxical part of it,
seemingly altruistic items.
Yeah.
Were actually correlated quite strongly with a form
of narcism, I've been studying called vulnerable narcissism,
which is different from grandiose narcism.
So I just wanted to look at this in a different way,
if that makes sense.
Right. But the constant in that is ego
and a sort of inflated sense of self-importance, right.
If I'm not this martyr and I'm giving everything
that I have, that the world will stop spinning on its axis.
Correct. That's why that's unhealthy selfishness.
But I think we can differentiate that kind
of unhealthy selfishness from a healthy form of selfishness.
So selfishness need not be bad or be egoistic.
Well, we need a different word then because selfish.
Fair enough.
Selfish is so negatively connotative.
Like, you need a different word for that.
I mean, self care, right?
Right.
Like you can't be the best servant unless
you're first looking after yourself, right?
Good point. (crosstalk) to redefine the dictionary.
No good point.
I think for a lot of people, it's like, well
like let's pick a single mom, who's working three jobs
and has a bunch of young kids at home. Right.
Like I don't feel, I have the time or the bandwidth
or it doesn't feel right to me
to take care of myself because so many other people
are dependent on me and I have to go out
and do all this other stuff.
Yeah. No, that's totally fair.
There is this egoistic, excessive self-focus,
excessive self-focus that is very much related
to narcissism, but I'm very interested in this kind
of vulnerable form of narcissism.
It's something that really fascinates me.
And I've been trying to do more research on
because it's not what we typically think of when we think
of narcissism and it can be covert actually in the '50s,
and '60s, the psychoanalyst called it covert narcissism.
Grandiose narcism is what we're obviously seeing a lot
of in the media. Right.
We're seeing the chest thumbing sort of like, I'm the best,
I'm gonna invade a whole country 'cause I'm the best.
That's grandiose narcissism
and that has its own problems for sure.
But there are some of these other forms that are very much,
there's the ones that a lot of them end up
on this clinician's couch.
I want to have empathy for it.
I mean, is that just a bad thing for us to have empathy
for people who score high in narcism
because they're being so self-destructive in their
own self-actualization goals.
If my goal is to help everyone self-actualize,
we need to look very non-judgmentally
and with unconditional positive regard at people
who are having all sorts of things that are
just getting in their own way internally.
I see vulnerable narcism and grandiose narcism
as well as people are just getting in their own way.
Things are not gonna turn out well for Putin.
I don't know if we can like bring current events in
(crosstalk) Sure.
But things are not gonna turn out well.
And there's gonna be a lot of destruction along the way,
a lot of unnecessary deaths.
And I just think that we need to, if we could just sit down,
if I could just sit down with Putin I'd be like, dude,
like do you wanna live a life of meaning of like growth
of satisfaction at all in your life?
Like you're not making the growth-oriented choices.
Yeah. And how do you,
like if you had to clinically diagnose him
and his motivations and what's driving him to make.
There's a rule against us doing that by the APA.
There's a rule that psychologists. Yeah.
They bring like the FBI to your room if you do.
Oh, wow.
No, I'm joking about that part.
But there is a rule, there is like an ethical standard
that if you're a psychologist you're not supposed
to diagnose public figures.
With that said.
Can you theorize?
With that said, I wrote before Trump was elected,
I wrote an article for "Scientific American",
trying to explain to everyone like, look,
this is exactly how he thinks.
This is exactly what's gonna happen if you elect him
as president. I was right.
I was right.
Was that narcissistic of me to say that?
But I think it's very important
without putting specific psychiatric labels on people
we haven't formally diagnosed as psychologist,
we still absolutely, you can see the ranks on the wall
with the way, the certain pattern, the ways of being again,
it comes back to ways of being,
there's a certain way of being that Putin has,
a certain way of being that Trump has,
there's a way of being well, everyone Biden has,
I don't mean to just pick on,
one thing like or one sort of political venue
'cause there's a lot of problems every which way you look
with ways of being on the political spectrum.
But I that there's a certain meglo maniac sort of way
of worldview of way of seeing the world
that is just so destructive.
But it's also so self-destructive,
it's not doing good for anything.
Right and what's interesting is that is the lack
of self-awareness around that, right?
Like it's evident to someone like yourself,
how this is gonna play out because that way of being
is fairly accurate in terms of behavior prediction
and the actions he's gonna take next.
And yet whether his advisors are pointing this out to him
or not, he's unable to see it for himself.
Or if it is pointed out to him,
he refuses to acknowledge it or to act on that information.
And I'm sure it's more complicated than
I wish your mother loved you better when
whatever hot takes are happening on the internet.
But yeah, it is fascinating.
I saw that video too, by the way.
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, yeah.
That poor (crosstalk) the internet ganged up on her,
pretty severely for that.
But if you could, are you allowed to say like,
if you could sit down with him and say, look man,
here's what you need to think about right now.
What would you say?
I mean, I think like what if I was his coach?
Yeah.
What if I was his self-actualization coach,
really to understand, well, what are your goals
and what I try to do in a very nonjudgmental way
with whatever client, what are your goals?
And if there are goals that things
I personally wouldn't agree with or wouldn't really like,
I'm still try to be nonjudgmental.
So like if I had as a client and I would be,
and he was like, my goal is to rule the world.
It's like, okay, okay.
Unconditional positive regard. I'm not gonna judge that.
But like, what are the best things you could be doing
to do along those lines?
I feel as though he made a huge error by so robustly
and dramatically attacking a whole,
it took to all the world to see there was no strategy there.
For someone who's supposed to be such a good chess player,
I think he, at one point he says,
he's like the grand master of thinking about strategy of war
and stuff, this wasn't very good strategy.
Like I would probably sit down with him now.
I wouldn't wanna like be like help him with the strategy
but help him really just think through, based on your goals,
do you have any goal at all of growing as a human being,
of being a better person?
Is that at all a goal for you?
Like do you have any goal, do you want to like,
have, do you probably feel every day you're like
and he probably feels a lot of inner conflicts, right?
Or maybe not again, I'd be curious to know.
Do you ever feel like there are things pulling you
in different directions inside of you that you want
to harmonize in any way and the process
of inner, feeling comfortable within your own self
and not feeling you have to constantly prove something.
In coaching we have something called powerful questions,
right so what are powerful questions that you can ask
to help transform a person?
I think a really powerful question in asking all of us is,
are there inner conflicts within you that if they
were resolved this big grandiose motivation
you have would be quelled?
And I do think in for most of us, yes, they would.
We often find there are a lot
of grandiose narcissistic dreams and goals we had
at one point which we just totally don't have anymore
because we've done inner work,
we haven't invaded a country to solve that problem.
I would also ask him as a powerful question,
if you get what you want, you get your goal,
do the thought experiment,
how will you actually feel any different inside, internally?
So these kinds of questions where you really try to help
and you work starting from within as opposed
to from without.
I don't feel like humans are very good at predicting
how they're gonna feel when they get the thing
that is driving them.
That's very true too.
We all think that that is gonna satisfy a certain need.
And it's only upon arrival that we realize it doesn't.
And then we just double down and keep climbing
that ladder adding (indistinct).
Daniel Gilbert has done great work on that,
effective forecasting.
We're terrible effective forecasting.
Connection is a big piece here too, right?
Like when you're talking about Putin, I'm wondering
what are his relationships really like? Right.
And connection being integral in this hierarchy.
You used (indistinct) as an example,
the centenarians who also inextricably wed to each other
and how that creates a level of contentment
and purpose in their lives
that is like a life force, right?
That spills over into every positive emotion
that we all want to experience.
And you think of someone like Putin,
isolated, probably keeps
whoever he's exposed to at a minimum.
And he's just an example.
It can be, think of your own life
and what your relationships are like.
And I've done a lot of work around this recently
because I've realized that I haven't been as good
a friend as I could to my friends out there
because I have kids and this work and this is
my social life is sort of doing
what we're doing right now.
And I feel that missing in my life.
Like that's an incongruity that I know I need to resolve
in order to continue on this self-actualization trajectory.
That's amazing that you have that awareness though.
And I mean, you've made that understanding.
You have that understanding that's something you need
to work on. Yeah.
I mean, if we ever stop finding things to work on,
that's a boring life like I think that I.
It never ends.
It never ends and I don't understand why some people come
in with the goal that it will end like some clients, right.
Like, or just people have this notion again,
like it's like a hierarchy, a pyramid.
I need to check a few boxes.
Yeah, it's always good to have something.
It's good that you're working on.
The other thing in thinking about the hierarchy
and reading your book and reflecting on my own path
that I found interesting was that I made certain decisions
that probably should have come later
on this evolutionary arc, but out of pain and necessity
was trying to kind of expedite it.
Like I was in a situation where some fundamental needs
were not being met.
Like we were having a really hard time just paying the bills
and logic would dictate like, hey,
you should maybe go back to a law firm
and get a stable paycheck.
And yet I made the choice to pursue these creative things
as a different way out that ended up taking a lot longer
and were very precarious and risky at the time.
And luckily like everything worked out fine,
but it wasn't like a kind of lockstep, rational model
for progressing through these various stages.
But you definitely chose the growth option though.
And again like self-actualization oh,
I don't think I made this point yet,
but self-actualization is not the same thing as achievement.
Self-actualization is not the same thing as making money.
In fact, I watched an interview with Maslow's wife,
Bertha after Maslow died
and Bertha said something very interesting.
She said Maslow always said when I asked him who's
the most self-actualized person you think exists
in this world, he would always say my mom.
So Bertha's mom and then she ended,
she described her mom as just the most loving person,
the most likely, like really comfortable in her own skin.
Just always like lid up a room.
But like not, very unassuming as well.
Not having achieved a lot. Right.
Maslow could have like chosen anyone
and he chose like, he mentioned Bertha's mom
as a great example of a self-actualized person.
I think a lot of that comes down to what
you yourself really wanna do in your life.
How will you feel most alive?
How you feel most creative,
how will you contribute the most?
But part of that self-actualization process doing that,
despite the pressure, societal pressures for money,
despite the societal pressures to achieve,
to have more Twitter following,
to be an influencer on Instagram,
that's a big thing these days is all that pressure.
You can kind of feel like a loser if you go on Instagram
and like you get like five likes for saying something,
but you see someone who says the same exact thing you said
and they have like 500,000 likes.
You could feel like a loser in life,
but that doesn't mean that you not self-actualizing.
It doesn't mean that other person has self-actualized.
I can't tell you the amount of people that I've talked to,
just like people I'm in awe of, people I think
they've accomplished so much.
And I talk to them and I get a beer with them or whatever,
whatever the choice of drink is
and they're like, I'm depressed.
I'm like, how the heck are you depressed?
There's still things they're aren't doing in their life.
They're not actually self-actualizing.
So I think we need to do that right away.
We need to divorce self-actualization from
these other constructs we have that we have made
in our society to be out like that's success.
When I reflect on the people that I know
that are pretty advanced on the self-actualization scale
and perhaps living a transcendent life,
there's a certain energy, like when they're in the room,
like you know it, right.
You feel it like, this is a person who knows who they are.
They're confident, but not arrogant.
They have healthy boundaries,
but they're also incredibly gracious and curious and loving.
Yeah.
They just, they know who they are and they exude
a certain kind of energy that's this mix of like love,
gratitude, presence, appreciation.
Like I said, confidence.
And it's almost as if there's something in the human brain
that is calibrated to recognize and appreciate that.
Yeah. Yeah.
And you're like, I wanna be like that, right.
What is that?
They're comfortable in their own skin
and you scientifically, I can break down what that means.
Yeah.
I mean, they're not fighting a civil war
within themselves.
They're not fighting, there are not parts of themselves
that are going in so many different directions.
I mean, you can take the converse of what you just said.
And you kind of like when someone walks in a room who like
is fighting this internal war, you know.
Oh yeah, like I need to get away from that person.
And those people actually tend to be the ones that tend
to be very manipulative and to be the ones that like,
are like constantly scheming.
But I do find it interesting phenomenon
that those who are very, very comfortable in their own skin
don't feel as much a need to manipulate others
to satisfy, it's because they're not coming
from a place of deficiency.
They're coming from a place of growth.
Maslow made this distinction between deficiency realm
of existence and the being realm or the growth realm
of human existence.
So many people are stuck in this deficiency realm where all
their motivations are being driven by their deficiencies.
And that's what I'm talking about with the person
who's not comfortable in their own skin
because they'll come in a room,
but their ways are focused on like I need,
they know they need something.
So then they're searching for
who can give them what they need.
Everything is transactional.
Well, you're talking about the kind of people who walk
in a room and they just wanna grow.
They wanna play, they wanna explore.
I love people like that.
Right and they will be equally interested in other people,
right, that curiosity.
And that's very different from the person who's pretending
to be interested in you because they're trying
to extract something out of you.
Yeah.
And even if the words are exactly the same,
the energy is completely different
and you know it immediately.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
That kind of dovetails into some interesting ideas
that you have around authenticity.
Like authenticity is sort of this catchphrase that has.
Whole other topic.
Yeah. Then sort of, I don't know, commodified I suppose.
We're all aspiring to be authentic
and there's a high premium for people
who are authentic online.
So what does that actually mean?
And there's some interesting science that you've written
about perhaps authenticity kind of all being
an a proper rubric or perhaps just a complete fallacy.
Yeah. I think there are a lot of things.
We use the phrase authenticity for
that aren't really authenticity.
So there's idea that if you just say what's ever
on your mind at any point and time like,
oh, I'm just being authentic.
No, you're being an asshole.
No, that's the term for that is asshole, not authentic.
Or this idea that if you realize all your darkest impulses
all the time, like you're really being authentic.
I view authenticity like I view everything else.
So I said earlier that I don't think anything really good,
bad by itself, I think there's a healthy flavor to it.
And there's a deficiency-motivated flavor.
We could say a growth-oriented flavor
and a deficiency-motivated flavor.
I think authenticity is the same.
So in what I tried to talk about is the construct
of healthy authenticity which is how can you realize
your potentialities in a really, in a way
that you're really truthful but is helping you learn
and grow, helping people around you grow.
So authentic relationships,
I think are ones that are very honest,
but they're ones that are honest.
You're not just having authentic relationship
when you just say like, hey man, you're ugly.
Like I'm just telling the truth.
I'm doing being your friend. Tough love.
No, I think like authentic relationships,
truthfulness is a part of it, but I think there's
a flavor of healthy authenticity where
there's a genuine spirit and motivation that we're both here
to help each other grow.
And I wanna and you wanna grow as a person.
So sometimes that means that the authentic choice
in my definition is having self-control over certain
of your urges, regulating certain things you say.
Like really thinking through,
if I say this on Twitter right now,
is that really me being authentic or is that,
is that a healthy form of authenticity?
Is it a way that's gonna signal to the others
and is gonna help anyone?
Is it gonna make the world a better place?
Is it gonna make me grow in any way if I say it?
Then don't say it.
So I think like healthy authenticity has a different flavor
than deprivation-motivated.
Right, well motivation is important, right?
What is the motivation behind that behavior or that action.
And in order to develop self-awareness around that you have
to do enough internal work,
where you get a better understanding of what your presets
are and your motivations and your deficiencies
and your character defects and the like, right.
Like if you're operating impulsively or reactively
to the world, you're not really in touch with your interior,
the interior space that is compelling these behaviors.
So how does one, like you have to that's the work, right?
Like you gotta be able to excavate your own self
to understand all of that.
And again, I go back to 12-step because that's the model
that I've used to, we call them character defects
and trying to understand what's behind them.
Yeah. So I have like various components
of healthy authenticity.
Two of them are ones you basically just touched on,
self-honesty and self-awareness are two huge ones.
You can just work on those two to start with,
not just you in particular, but everyone.
I'm not saying you need to work on those.
I have plenty I need to work on.
Me too. Me too but I just be clear.
If anyone can start working on those on a path
to healthy authenticity I think, those are good phases.
There's more to healthy authenticity in those two.
But how many of us are really self-honest?
I did something a bit cheeky in my book,
which you rarely seen a self-help space, which are like,
I'm here, take this test of narcissism,
take this test of psychopathy.
Are you a psychopath?
Maybe you are like be really,
really piercingly honest with yourself.
I feel like I am constantly honest with myself and I do it
with a sense of humor and love though.
Like it's really good I think to laugh at yourself.
I think that people who score really, really high
on psychopathy lack self-humor.
And the correlation is almost perfect.
Yeah.
Can you think of anyone in your head,
like who is a big public figure,
who is like just like severe lack of empathy.
It's so obvious and they never laugh at themselves.
You never see that so I think a big part of that
is self-honesty, self-awareness and having
and cultivating relationships that are grounded in truth,
but grounded in truth in a way that has a direction to it.
And this, by the way, some people might disagree with that.
There's a mega disagreement sometimes
with my heterodox of friends, intellectual friends, I think.
Put a pin in that 'cause we're gonna talk about that,
but go ahead.
The idea of truth at all costs, we can talk about that
'cause I actually disagree with that.
I think truth. I'm not saying lying is good,
but we don't have to say everything.
We don't have to do everything.
I think cultivating a real authentic relationship
where you genuinely care and are listening
to the other person divorced from your own real felt needs,
right so it's not like you're always trying
to get something out of the other person.
You're actually with wonder and curiosity,
witnessing a friend,
I think is a big part of an authentic relationship.
And in your experience, how malleable are these traits,
curiosity, empathy, like these things we come
with our presets obviously and there are things
that we can do to cultivate or breed them.
But somebody who is pathologically narcissistic
and lacks any kind of empathy,
is it possible for that person to become more empathetic?
Or how do we cultivate these traits that can elevate us on
this self-actualization path?
Well, that's a billion dollar question.
Yeah.
If I had the magic sauce and if we could put it
in the water supply for everyone to have, but I think a lot
of it does come down to a matter of perspective.
It comes down to a matter of frame of reference.
There are self-transcendent states we get
in their self-transcendent practices that allow us
to glimpse moments of what that could look like, aided
or unaided by drugs.
I'm not anti drugs by any stretch of the imagination.
There's some really exciting research coming out
about psychedelics, the extent to which it can change
our frame of reference.
But I think an even more interesting question is
how can we get those states of consciousness without having
to take whatever your psychedelic drug of choice is.
And I think there are things that we can do.
I'm really interested in the emotion
and psychological phenomenon of awe, A-W-E.
It's a concept I've scientifically studied with people
like Dr. Keltner and David Yeaton trying to create a scale
and having people report on their experiences of awe.
So we did a large scale study where we had people
just freeform, tell us about your greatest moments of awe
and try to (indistinct) and find the commonalities.
And we create a scale,
the all experienced questionnaire based
and it has six facets to it.
But the point here is that when you look at
these descriptions of the awe state, you find that
they're infused with other, with getting outside yourself.
They're infused with ideas of a complete shift
in perspective.
In some cases, a quite profound shift in perspective,
like things like, wow, my whole life, I thought
that like this was my path.
Or I thought that the world only worked in this way.
And then I discovered or witnessed something that was so
beyond my comprehension, so outside of myself,
that I realized that I had been so self-focused
this whole time.
So I think we can get these moments.
Some people, religious people may find it in prayer.
Meditation practices show a lot of promise in it.
There are a whole wide range of you called
them spiritual practices or transcendent practices.
I like to secularize it, but pairing it with sometimes
even pairing it with psychedelics is be found to show huge,
huge, positive effects, right?
The psychedelics will deliver you a guaranteed response,
right that you're gonna have to reckon with,
but there are all these other modalities
for tapping into that.
I mean, the Grand Canyon, right?
You talk about these different various peak experiences
that we can have.
I've experienced them as an athlete.
I've experienced them in meditation.
And in other context in my life,
but also is not like connection to other human beings
back to the connection piece,
like being in communion with other human beings,
the ultimate breeder of empathy,
because the more people you're connected to
or the more cultures and also travel and exposure
to different things is gonna make
you a more empathetic human.
The broader you can develop your understanding
of the human condition.
Yeah. Empathy and compassion are different things.
And I think that's is an important distinction.
A lot of people call themselves,
have you heard people who call themselves
they self-identify as empaths.
Yes.
We did a study on that, you're gonna love this.
We found actually that's core with narcissism.
Yeah. Well, that's the whole,
the spiritual narcissism thing that you've (crosstalk)
which is a super interesting topic because I'm kind of part
of that, I'm congenital to that world.
I'm very familiar with the condition
that you're talking about.
Yeah. And I also wanna make quick,
before I get hate mail from empaths, which is funny,
and that idea is funny in itself that I would get hate mail
from empaths but I'm not talking about perfect correlation.
But all, everyone who identify (indistinct) empaths
is really narcism. I'm not saying that.
So calm down empaths.
There are people who are generally have a abundance
of empathy, they immediately feel
what other people feel like.
And they, it can be overwhelming for them
because they are constantly, have very little boundaries
between self and others and that can really exist.
But there are those who self-identify as empaths
that have this notion that like they're really special
in some really like narcissistic way.
Like I'm a real healer, but I'm,
by the way, you find that the higher proportion of this
among those who call themselves healers.
Again, not all, but there's this idea that like, I and only
I can save you, right?
And there's a kind of grandiosity there that may not take
into account the real felt needs of another person.
But I think compassion is a little bit different.
With compassion, you don't have to feel what another person
is feeling to want to alleviate their suffering
'cause you see the suffering right in front of your eyes.
You can be more in tune with the real felt needs of others.
There are a lot of people who in a narcissistic way view
themselves as healers or helpers,
but they're actually causing destruction in the person
they're helping because they're not paying real attention to
whether or not what they're giving the other person
is actually what the person needs.
It's actually more, it's correlated with intrusive ways
of intrusive helping, there's that whole concept
in psychology called intrusive helping.
My mom does this sometimes.
I love her so much, but she'll be like mail me,
like all these food, like all this stuff.
She'll like, see what I did?
I gave you all this, I was like,
I don't even want half of this.
It's like, I mean, God bless her.
Right.
Like she's wonderful.
But like, just to give you an example
like sometimes we do things to make ourselves feel good,
but we need to actually ask is that I really,
what is really in best for someone else?
I think compassion is really being able to look
at the real felt needs of others and to really try
to alleviate their suffering in a way that even
if you don't feel what they're feeling,
because sometimes we get in all sorts of trouble by thinking
that we know exactly what someone else is feeling.
That we're presuming that well, we just get exactly
what someone needs because we feel what they feel.
And we're not really doing them the best good
for themselves.
Or we're approaching it from a perspective of trying
to meet our own needs.
Yeah.
Like you can tell yourself that you're trying
to help your friend.
But really what you're trying to do is make yourself like,
oh, if I solve this person problem,
then I've fulfilled some need within inside myself.
It's deficiency motivation.
That has nothing to do with that person's need. Right?
Yeah. It's like a deficiency motivation.
Absolutely. Absolutely. Yeah.
How does trauma play into all of this?
I mean, humanistic psychology is really about
the elevated states of the human condition.
Yeah.
How do we sort of ascend as opposed to looking
at clinical deficiencies in humans per se,
but I feel like.
Yeah.
We live in these loops that are calcified when we're young
and these stories that we tell ourselves about who we are
and we're unconsciously aware that so much of our worldview
and behaviors originate from something that happened to us
before we were complete,
our brains were fully formed, et cetera.
So when you're thinking about these elevated states,
like do you not have to still rely upon different modalities
of psychology to help people unpack those things
in a more traditional mode to get to that place?
I didn't say that very elegantly,
but do you know what I mean?
There's just a lot there in what you just said.
Like there's a lot there's, a lot to unpack.
Different modalities. Yeah. Because.
I mean like CBT like, you know what I'm saying?
I do. And it's just such a complicated,
complex question because believe it or not,
we haven't all figured this out in psychology.
There are like, it's believe it or not.
(indistinct) out of a job.
We don't have our shit together.
I'd be very hubristic to say, okay, here's the answer
because there are different factions in psychology.
There are different, some people think like
this approach is the best to trauma,
some people, this approach is the best.
I'll tell you what I like.
I'll tell you what I like in the most modest way,
in the sense
that it's not necessarily gonna work for everyone.
But I really like Steven Hayes and his act approach,
the act approach is grounded in the idea that we need
to stop avoiding our experiences
that we're scared of.
Avoiding, a lot of people with trauma,
what they'll do is they'll run from any trigger, right.
They're scared of being triggered, right?
That's a word triggered, right.
And even you see that in college campuses with
like trigger warnings and research shows that backfires.
The best available evidence on this suggests
that if you even set up that expectation beforehand,
that like just so you know what I'm just about to say
to you, what I'm about to say to you is gonna trigger you
that already sets,
that's already like gonna set your expectations in a way.
It's basically saying you can't handle it.
Right.
What we wanna do more I think is build deep reserves
of resilience in people where they're like, I can handle it.
I've been through a lot and because I've been through
a lot, it has strengthened me.
So therefore, who cares about a couple words
that might trigger me, I can handle that.
We want people to have more resiliency.
So I really like the act approach because it's moving
in an approach oriented way towards,
in line with your values.
So value is a big part of the act approach.
So you're still saying,
and as long as you're moving with your values,
you don't avoid these things.
Right. This is consistent with Susan David's approach,
right emotional agility.
Absolutely, as well. Yeah.
You have to expose yourself to these things to,
it's like exercise.
You have to use your muscles to get stronger.
Yeah. Yeah. There's a lot of confluence
between Susan's approach and the act approach.
I really like both of them are my friends.
I like both of them and I like the approach very much,
but this whole idea of experiential avoidance
is a psychological construct and has just been shown
in hundreds and hundreds of studies now that it's in almost
every context imaginable that it's just not good.
Yeah. I'm thinking of people in my own life that practice
that and what the that's reaped in their lives.
Yeah.
And it isn't good.
Yeah. It's really, it's correlated with depression.
You're constantly reinforcing the wound as opposed
to healing it.
But post-traumatic growth is a whole different field
than overcoming just post-traumatic stress 'cause I think
there's more that we can do to just go
from negative 10 to zero.
Some people will go to a clinician and their goal,
their state of goal, I just wanna stop having reminiscence
about the events, the trauma.
I wanna just stop feeling so shitty all the time,
but I think we can do better than you're cured when
you just stop those things.
I think we can go to the positive 10, positive 20
and actually grow from those experiences
in really profound ways like seeing
a real fundamental reordering, reshaping of your priorities
in the life, feeling greater sense of connection
to others and a greater sense of love for humanity,
creative growth.
You find lots of different areas.
People can grow from these traumas in really profound ways.
Shame is a big issue in terms of getting people
to confront this stuff, right.
Huge. For everything.
Yeah.
Can I double click on shame for a second?
Yeah, yeah.
I think it is the one thing that's, at least
the personality trait neuroticism has,
but shame is a very strongly correlated with neuroticism.
It's the one thread that runs through every form
of diagnosis in the DSM.
If you had to find one thing to unravel where all, shame,
neuroticism, negative emotions, but shame is such a big one
because the moment you start to real radical self-acceptance
for a part of yourself you don't like,
it doesn't become an issue anymore.
Right. That's one of the most powerful things
about being in 12-step.
When you sit in these rooms and you see people get up in
front of groups of people, large and small.
Yeah.
And tell these insane stories about stuff
that they've done and they laugh about it and they inject it
with all kinds of color and drama.
And you just cannot believe that this person
is so comfortable telling this chapter of their life
that would be horrifically shameful and embarrassing
to anyone else.
And what it does is it gives you the permission to look at
your own relationship with shame and your past behaviors
and own it in a way such
that it no longer holds power over you.
And when you share that with other human beings,
it's a very attractive infectious thing that I think
is very powerful in helping other people confront
their own shame.
I completely agree. Can I stand up for one second?
Yeah.
My butt hurts.
No problem. Isn't that super comfortable chair
that I got you?
It is super.
You need to go to the bathroom or anything.
We take a quick break.
No, I just wanna like, you can capture
this and (indistinct).
Yeah, there you go.
You're being filmed. Scott.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to incorporate
more whole plants, more fruits, vegetables,
seeds, beans and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools
and support very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet transformed my life
so profoundly and because I want everybody
to experience some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is Plantpower Meal Planner,
our affordable all in one digital platform that sets you up
for nutrition excellence by providing access to thousands
of highly customizable, super delicious
and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team
of nutrition coaches, seven days a week
and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com. and right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life changing stuff, people for just
a dollar 70 a week, literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
All right. Scott had to shake his booty.
I took a bathroom break.
Where were we?
What were we talking about?
Self-acceptance you did ask me a really good question.
It was about, owning your behavior in a way
that basically dissipates shame.
Oh man. Shame is, it plays a role in so much of the work
I do in my life like I'm really interested
in like neurodiversity for instance,
I really wanna champion people whose brains are wired
in all sorts of different ways from like autism spectrum
to like bipolar disorder to dyslexia, schizophrenia,
like having self-acceptance for having
a uniquely wired brain is a game changer
for these individuals, right.
I think you're also seeing this play out
more controversially in the sort of trans movement.
A lot of these individuals who have gender identities
that are extraordinarily mismatched to their physical bodies
and that, by the way, that is a real scientific thing
that can happen for your psychological gender to differ
so dramatically from your physical genitalia that,
that experience is disorienting for people.
The question and what's controversial is what do
you do with that?
Do you call yourself a different gender or do you deal
with it in other ways?
And that's open for discussion and I think debate
but nevertheless, if you can have self-acceptance
over the fact that you are out there,
on a bell curve in an extreme way,
and you can get self-acceptance for that.
That's a huge game changer for them as well.
I mean, isn't that what we're all craving in a way.
There's a sort of a common humanity there.
I'm trying to bring up these disparate examples of,
these diverse examples, we're all human
at the end of the day.
And whenever we have any sort of extreme trait or something
that puts us out on a bell curve to have self-acceptance for
that and to not have shame over it is,
is gonna be a huge part of that self-actualization process.
Well, the self-acceptance provides the basis
for esteem, right?
And you need that esteem in order to create a rounded sense
of self and healthy boundaries.
Yeah.
Yeah. One of the things you talk about, let's talk,
I wanna talk about love and this difference
between de-love and be love.
I love that. I love that topic.
Yeah.
Well, when I was looking into the writings of Maslow
I came across a concept called being love.
And what does it mean to be love, day in and day out.
And he distinguished that from unneeding love.
So he distinguished needing love from unneeding love.
So when you have needing love,
that's more like a need for connection.
Like you need to connect with people all the time.
You need to constantly have that sort of find people
with similar values, similar ideas.
But I think be love is a higher form of spiritual love,
where you can love people even if you don't connect
with them, like you can be with someone even
if it's the opposite.
Like they're on the complete opposite end
of the political spectrum from you.
It seems unheard of these days
that you could potentially love someone
who has a complete opposite of this political spectrum,
but you can, there's no rule.
There's no like God like, thy shalt not love
thy neighbor who disagrees with you
on this dimension of politics.
No, you can and I think that's why it's a way of being,
it's an attitude. It's a verb, right.
Like it's not necessarily a feeling.
Yes. You might not feel love for that person,
but you can be loving for that person.
I think a big part of be love is what's called
a quiet ego is to lowering your ego just enough
where you can actually listen
to another person's perspective 'cause when our ego is
in full force and that volume is turned up all the way,
we're not listening at all to what the other person
is saying, we're already right.
And they're wrong.
Most people are looking at love at as something
they're trying to extract from another human being.
They're trying to get it.
They're trying to fill some hole or some need
that they have.
The boat has a lot of holes in it.
Yeah. And the idea being like, I will be complete when,
you complete me, like when I meet that perfect mate
and we're together, then everything is gonna be great.
As opposed to you this idea of be love where
you're exuding it, you're looking to contribute love.
And I just know for myself, when I descend
into self-obsession or I'm picking my fingernails
and gnawing my teeth on whatever is frustrating me
in the moment or why this isn't working out or whatever.
Like I have to practice the habit of like,
how can I contribute?
How can I exude my next encounter with something positive
for that person.
And the more that I practice that, which is not,
this is not my default state, Scott.
Like I'm a curmudgeon.
It's not?
No, like not at all.
I just know that I feel better.
The other person feels better. Everything's better.
And that self-obsession begins to wane.
But it's a practice. It's just like a muscle.
It's a habit that I have to cultivate.
And more often than not,
I don't think about it or I resist doing it
or I don't wanna to do it.
I think. How can you integrate it more though
into your being?
Because I think there's probably really positive aspects
of that curmudgeonly guy.
Like you've asked me some really critical questions today.
Like even just coming back with me, some stuff,
I wouldn't call it curmudgeonly at all.
That's not what I'm saying, but there like,
that side of you seeps through sometimes today.
And I view it as like a real positive because it's like,
there's maybe a more critical side of you
or a more like thoughtful.
So I guess just like, how can I be integrated
is my question.
Yeah. I mean, I think what I'm getting at more is,
as somebody who is devoted to trying to self-actualize
on some level I'm constantly, daily, hourly reminded of
these default sets that I have,
which is to not be grateful, but to be resentful.
I see.
Or to be irritated by other human beings.
Like, it's like kind of (indistinct) right.
But no matter how much devotion I have to personal growth
like this is like, these are weeds that continue to grow up
and probably will for the rest of my life no matter
what I do.
Yeah.
But the only solution is to persistently
like double down on these habits or these little practices
that I know, keep those negative behaviors and emotions
at bay and kind of present a better version of myself.
And it's sort of an act as if thing like.
Good on you, man.
You fake it until you make it kind of stuff
and that's a whole other sticky wicket,
but that seems to work for me.
But I guess my question is like,
do you ever get to a point where
that practice becomes second nature
and that default position is no longer the default?
Like in your practice of working with lots of people
over the years, have you seen that?
Yeah. Sometimes I do see it sort of an entire way
of being is replaced over time through habit change,
but not always the necessarily like you're saying to me
that no matter how many podcast interviews you've done,
how much you've exercised that way of being,
it's still not your default. Is that what you're saying?
Correct.
That's fascinating.
But it's also similar to listen, if I wanna
be a good runner, I gotta go out and run and train.
Like I'll never just wake up one day and be good at
that thing unless I'm consistently practicing it.
I guess there's a philosophical question here,
which no one can answer,
which is at what point have you changed the habits
of your personality structure so much that it has now become
your new personality?
Right.
I mean, I'm interested.
That's a broader subject
of like personality malleability overall.
Yeah. And I've written a bit about the science of that
and there are limits, but we can quite profoundly change,
but there are biological temperaments.
And I think this is what you're hinting at.
That may be your consider default.
I have friends, people who they say I'm biological,
I'm an introvert but in terms of my actions in the world,
I'm very extroverted, right?
'Cause there are people I would assume they're extroverted,
but they're explaining to me they're inner experiences,
biologically, I'm an introvert and that might
not be something that ever goes away. Right?
But when you are acting extroverted and you're doing
those things, is it you or not you?
I mean that's the default philosophical question there.
And I would argue that it's still part of you,
it's still an authentic part of you
that you're not faking it.
It's just that there
are certain default biological temperaments that also exist.
But those only influence the sort of probabilities that you
will be in a certain mode of being.
But it's not saying those other modes of being aren't you.
This gets a little philosophical.
Yeah. Yeah. I guess an extreme example of that
or a thought experiment would be to take somebody
who is on one far end of the political spectrum,
like an AOC or a Bernie Sanders type individual
and that person saying, okay,
I'm going to now behave as if I'm the person
on the complete opposite end of the political spectrum
and everything that comes out of my mouth
and all the content that I consume and all the interactions
I'm going to have, I'm going to mimic that person
on the other end of the spectrum.
If they do that long enough,
do they ultimately become that person?
Do they shift or will they rubber band back to being
that person that they were prior?
The scientists in me is saying, well,
we have to do that experiment.
Right.
We have to do that experiment.
But I do think there are ways we can change
and grow profoundly. But I think at the end of the day,
we have to still be in line with a certain core set
of values or else it won't feel authentic.
I wrote about this exact, I pondered this exact question.
I wrote a couple articles for "The Atlantic" about this.
Can you change your personality was one,
but the other one was I forget the title of the other one,
but it was really much along that exact,
answering that question, looking at the research.
And the research shows that you have people who, even if
they're acting in a different way,
if it's not in line with their values,
they don't feel authentic.
There still has to be a reason for why you're doing
the personality change.
And often the reasons for the personality change
are still grounded in here by all.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Like for me, if I let's say I set out a goal tomorrow,
I wanna be a huge asshole.
That's my goal. I wanna completely change.
I'm tired of people-pleasing.
I'm tired of having to smile all the time
when I meet someone, it's exhausting,
I wanna just become the biggest asshole.
And so then I just like, I wake up,
who's the biggest asshole in the world and I mimic
them all the time.
Will there ever be a point where that will become authentic
and probably not, there probably is, you have to change
for a reason, right.
And some of that does come back
to who you actually biologically are to a certain degree.
That's so interesting.
It's a fascinating topic. Isn't it?
Now I do think I could use to be like 25% more asshole
and like 25% less people-pleaser. So I think just.
Right and if you're so exhausted by having to smile all
the time, then isn't your true self somebody
who shouldn't be smiling all the time?
Yeah. Well, I mean, I was joking about that actually,
love smiling, but I was just doing a thought experiment.
Yeah, but you're right. You're absolutely right.
Like what is a,
and it goes back to that question of like,
is authenticity a real thing?
And what does that mean specifically?
Yeah. I don't think there is a real self.
I mean, people in the spiritual world,
they can't touch, you listen to meditation things.
I disagree with some of the things people say
in these meditation apps like, am I allowed
to disagree with it?
Like, close your eyes. You are enough as it is.
It's like, no, you're not.
And those say things like, your real self is all you need.
It's like, no, it's not.
I don't know. I think we let people off the hook too easily,
sometimes in that spiritual space
and we don't encourage growth.
Yeah.
But I do believe in growth as well,
but I don't think there is that real self.
I think they're just multitude of selves, right.
And we are constantly shifting between them.
We have evolutionary evolved selves, like the kind of self
that becomes triggered in a mating context. Right.
And like that has an evolutionary foundation going way back.
Is that not your true, no, that's a part of you,
but I think we have other sides of ourselves.
I think we have probably higher.
We do probably have higher selves that probably
is a coherent construct, not real self.
You would have to believe in that if you believe
in Maslow, right.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, this is your whole thing.
Yeah. But the idea that the higher self is your real self
I don't agree with that.
I think that there are lots of real parts of the organism.
Right. But we all walk around with this delta
between the person we actually are and the person
we aspire to be.
Aspire to be.
Or, and maybe there's an additional delta in there
between the person we are, the person we think we are,
which is usually puts a positive spin on who you actually
are and the person we aspire to be, right.
So the person we aspire to be being that higher self,
that we're all consciously and unconsciously trying to work
towards to reduce that delta.
And then people who have really grandiose ambitions
and think that they're capable
'cause there's something deeper there.
It's not just who you want to be.
It's who you think you're capable of becoming
and you want to be.
And it's interesting because would that be a great tragedy
to think in your head that you are capable that you
could be this person and then find out on your death bed
like no, that wasn't possible.
It was never.
That really wasn't you or possible to be you.
And then does it feel like you've wasted so much
of your life?
I mean, these are really deep, profound questions
to get at the heart of human existence and what it means
to have a human existence.
Yeah. Anyway.
Well, that also works in the opposite direction, right?
Like if you have some success, then your sense
of personal possibility expands.
Yeah. It does. It really does.
I mean I'm into the growth mindset.
I mean I'm on like a fixed mindset.
What do you mean, you're on long walks
with Angela Duckworth.
I mean, come on.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, we're down with the Carol Dweck's work.
It makes sense, but it's constantly calibrating.
Carol Dweck. Sorry I misspoke there.
Oh, no problem. No, but Angela talks a lot
about growth mindset. So that was apt. That was apt as well.
But the constant calibration process is key.
Constantly grounding yourself in the reality of who you are
in your pursuit of who you want to become,
but I think we can get, especially if we get power
and you see that you see that power intoxicates people.
It makes them start to think that they're capable
of becoming all sorts of things that makes
them have decisions that actually do the exact opposite.
You can fool you into thinking you could accomplish
all sorts of things that you get into this kind
of mania state.
So I think, look, I think it's tricky
because we wanna absolutely encourage people to dream
and to have high ambitions,
but we should also have them constantly calibrate who they
are right now and who they really truly
are capable of becoming because in the long run,
being in line with that reality will lead
to a better outcome, won't it?
Yeah.
If you're actually in line with who you could become.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Back to that point that you were making about self-help
and meditation apps and your sort of reaction
to some of those statements.
Yeah.
There is something interesting about the inherent tension
between or the paradoxical kind of relationship
between this idea that expansion, self-actualization
is actually a lot of work.
Like, you don't just get it right.
Like you have to actually work towards it.
Yeah.
And it's something you have apply consistently
over extremely long periods of time versus this notion
that we already have everything we need. Right.
And we just have to expand our conscious awareness
and recognize it.
And that is more of the ephemeral allowing kind of thing.
Right. So how do those two things like coexist for you?
Sounds like you're more on the former, less on the latter.
Yeah, it's true.
And I talk about this in the book, "Transcend".
Maslow's students at Brooklyn College,
he said they had this notion of self-actualization
that it was impulsivity.
It was just acting on a whims, just do what you want.
It was easy, if you just were in line with yourself
and he made it very, very clear
that self-actualization requires commitment and requires
a lot of hard work because it's tough choosing
the growth option day in and day out.
You said, you told me your thank you for being vulnerable
by the way, you told me your own personal struggles with
of that with your default versus the person,
you know you're capable of and you are capable of it.
Right. You're right now.
This guy in front of me is this incredibly non-curmudgeonly,
thoughtful kind human being. Right.
So it takes a lot, but it takes a lot of work.
And were you asking though my own and personal life,
like, were you asking me personally how that plays out?
No, I'm it would less, more just like theoretically,
like how you think about psychology in general.
Yeah, yeah.
Theoretically, absolutely I think there's a difference
between spontaneous and impulsive.
I think self-actualization is, there is
a certain spontaneity there there's a certain sort
of playfulness and exploration and curiosity,
but that's different than kind of impulsive,
not seeing the bigger picture of the long term
or working very, very hard at something that might
not pay off for 10, 20 years.
Self-actualization process in a lot of ways is being able
to have that foresight and being able to work really hard
towards that future vision.
Yeah. I think the impulsivity thing
is a really important point.
The way I think about that is someone who is saying,
I am acting in alignment with my highest nature,
because my intuition is telling me X,
but if they've short circuited, the hard work,
how can they trust their intuition or their instincts
because they are disconnected?
And this plays out in the recovery context when people
are new and they've stopped drinking or using,
and suddenly they're just a live wire of emotions
and they have no way of controlling it.
Their instincts are unreliable.
They're trying to solve their problems with the mind
that got them there in the first place.
And they're taught, we're taught, I was taught to abdicate,
making big decisions and making sure that you run them by
other people because your instincts are unreliable.
Like you have to do enough internal work before you can have
a trusted relationship with whatever those impulses
are telling you.
And I think there's a lot of people out there who believe
that they are on this path towards self-actualization
when instead they're really just reacting
to unconscious impulses that have been driving
them all along.
Wow.
Does that make sense?
Does that like deal, feel right to you?
Oh yeah. Spot on. Yeah. Spot on.
I'd love to double click on that moment
of real, sheer vulnerability where you stop doing the drug
or you stop drinking and you're raw,
you're emotional and it's craving this other side of you
that you so consciously,
desperately don't wanna become that person.
Can we double click on that experience?
What is that experience like?
What is it, what are the strategies that people are taught
in the program to be with those emotions and to overcome it
and not give in because there's a huge payoff
for not giving in.
I mean, people who can resist it and go through that torture
and come out on the other side, feel, report such
a increased sense of meaning in their life.
Yeah.
There's a meaning making that can happen
from that resistance.
Sure. But unfortunately, that payoff is long term.
Long term.
The immediate payoff of indulging
the addiction is guaranteed.
Yeah. Oh, totally.
So it's very difficult to get people,
to wrap their heads around the long term benefits
of sobriety when they're just trying to get through the day.
So it's all about what are you doing in this very moment
and creating community and accountability
around that individual and providing them
with some pretty basic tools to just help
them get through those intense periods of craving so
that they begin to understand that those feelings
are not facts and that they will shift over time.
And if you can weather that intense moment of craving,
then it provides you with some confidence
that you could do it again.
And you just start to stack those experiences.
Yeah.
But relapse is a big part of recovery.
And I think relapse is often looked at as failure,
but sometimes it's just really good information
about what your triggers are and what kind
of interior emotional experiences lead you
to indulge that behavior.
Yeah. Well, I mean, everything you're saying,
I agree with so much that I'm like I have nothing
to add to that.
Yeah.
No, I think that's exactly right.
Addiction is its own special topic, right within psychology.
That's a whole different thing.
Sure.
And addiction is absolutely a big inhibitor
of self-actualization for the same reason that having
a severe deprivation of any of your needs
is significantly inhibiting who you could become.
Well, it's all consuming.
I mean, you can't think about anything else,
there's no room for any kind of personal development
when that is active.
Yeah. Whenever there's any, well,
we can actually generalize this to Rollo May
had this idea of the dimonic.
Always liked this concept.
Never understood why it didn't catch on more
in the general public, but we can have like the demonic,
but that's not what he's talking about.
He's saying there's a side of ourself whatever is within us,
they can overtake the whole person.
He calls it the, the dimonic, D-I-M-O-N-I-C.
And it's not necessarily bad.
It could entirely take over and call self-destruction
and destruction of others or it can be channeled in a way
that can lead to creativity like you've never seen.
So many people take their pain,
their suffering and they take their demons and they use it
as fuel for being able to think it more longer term about
how they're gonna just use it as fuel,
use it as fuel for the work they do,
the fuel they do to help others who have been addicted,
to help others who are in a similar situation themselves,
whatever it is, they just,
they integrate it in such a way that it's the demonic
becomes their creative fuel.
Yeah. It's interesting.
I question how sustainable that fuel source is because pain
is akin to other base emotions that tend to be unhealthy
in terms of being primary motivators.
But I do like this subject of pain being a lever for growth.
And I think when I was on your podcast,
I believe we talked about this.
Yeah.
Like change is always accessible for us.
We always in every moment have the opportunity to make
a better choice about something about us, right.
But we generally don't do it.
Pain can actually put us in that place to confront
that thing we don't like about ourselves
and make the better choice.
And I just know, I know for myself that pain
has really been the true motivator in getting me
to do anything different than I have historically.
So how does that work in terms of
this self-actualization process or cycle,
because it is very powerful when you can channel it
in a positive direction.
And I'm very reluctant to intervene in someone's life
who's having a painful experience because I recognize that,
although it looks bad and as a compassionate human being,
you wanna ameliorate that in somebody you care about,
but also you don't wanna rob them of that experience
because it might just be their greatest teacher.
It really might. Yeah.
Yeah. So there's different ways of like
in getting into that question, one is, well,
as a therapist or as a coach and you're working
with someone directly and you wanna help them grow,
who is experiencing that, I think that that's quite right
is you want to, you don't wanna tell them
how to live their lives.
It's very important to not give people exact steps
that they need to follow to curb something,
but to help them be with things and help them get more
in touch with their values.
Again, that's we go back to the act approach to therapy,
which I really like is it's a constant reorienting towards
these higher values.
And sometimes it's a matter of shift of increasing
that in your intentional field, like writing it out
on a piece of paper, whatever,
make it your freaking screen saver of your phone.
Every time you open your phone, it's like, I'm oh,
oh, that's what I'm doing in my life,
because we can so easily forget.
There are so many inner forces within us.
I mean, this happens to me all the time.
I'm human too.
I'll get down, I'll be on Twitter and I'll find myself
down some rabbit hole fighting with some anonymous person
with no name and no picture about the most minute thing.
And I'm like, wait, Scott, wait a minute.
Yeah.
I'm, that's not what I'm on earth to do.
And then I recalibrate and sometimes when I get in
those moments I will say it energizes me to go back
to my mission in a way, even before I've, it's like,
oh, because I know what it feels like when I'm working
on my mission, when I'm working on the things
that are in value,
I can differentiate the different feelings.
So also, it's helping people if like if you're in a kind
of a healing, helper role with someone who is suffering
or going through this, it's also getting them
in different states and having them explore and have
the self-awareness and understanding
of how these different states feel.
What kind of states do you wanna be in?
Who do you want to become?
A lot of that is really non-judgmental
and non-advice-giving but helping explore the full depth
of human experience with that person in being
there with them, supporting them in their journey of that.
Yeah. I mean, just from my own non-clinical kind
of modality of dealing with that,
I just try to be present and loving and express to them
like I'm here for you and I believe in you.
Like that's it like, I'm not gonna solve your problem.
I understand that you're in a painful moment
and that that's difficult and I can empathize with that.
Do you now why I'm laughing?
Yeah why?
'Cause my butt hurts right now.
Oh, really, from the chair again?
You're the only guest that's had a problem with the chair.
You're here with me on this journey.
Did you adjust it?
I'm the first, because the thing is,
I'm sure it's like objectively a really
like profoundly comfortable chair that like everyone loves.
This is why I'm weird.
It's ergonomically fit.
Do we have one of the?
No, no, that'd be ridiculous.
We have the stool. Do we have one of those stools?
And we have a couple more.
I was just laughing because I was cheekily thinking
as you're talking to me about being one with someone
with their pain that I was like, yeah, yeah.
I'm just injecting a little humor into our conversation.
No it's good. Yeah. Try this.
That one goes out. That might be better.
Yeah.
Are we really changing the chair?
Yeah. I want you to be comfortable.
Okay, okay.
And it goes up and down.
Is that better or is it worse?
Let's try it. Let's try it.
You're not sold.
Let's try it.
Don't they just have no normal chairs?
What's wrong with these people?
I'm debating whether this was healthy authenticity
in my part though.
I appreciate it.
Okay, good. I took a risk.
Listen. No, this is, this is good.
Like let's dissect this, I would much rather you say like,
I got a problem with this chair than like sit there,
like clench jawed.
Yeah.
Feeling like you can't tell me what's going on.
Thank you.
So this is a healthy.
Thank you. Good.
Good, good, good, good.
What we talking about? Oh, we were talking about.
We're literally talking about being with someone
who's in pain.
Yeah.
And how do you interact with them?
How do you help them and guide them in their journey?
And that's the point is you guide people
in their journey and they have to figure out for themselves
how they can, resiliency is something
you can only like build that muscle within yourself.
Like you can't like force someone to build those muscles.
Right. I wanna shift gears a little bit.
You mentioned getting into Twitter spats.
Can we talk, spend a few minutes talking
about the psychology of the "culture war" right now
that is transpiring on social media at least,
and spilling out into the world with real life consequences.
It does feel, I spend a lot of time thinking about this
and I find myself fascinated and captivated by the sort
of ecosystem of secular gurus online right now.
Yeah.
And how that plays into the root causes
of what is currently dividing us.
How we can heal as a nation and trying to understand
it better and I'm concerned about the incentives that are
at play online and this appeal of heterodox thinking
and thinkers that appear to dominate certain issues
in which a lot of people find very powerless to resist.
So whether it's politics or health, nutrition,
vaccines, there seems to be this allure,
like a tractor beam to this manner of issue,
dissection that lures for better or worse,
many people into thought bubbles that become calcified.
And I'm not necessarily interested
in parsing the validity of various ideas,
but I'm more interested in the kind of psychological drivers
behind all of this and the binary nature of all of it,
because it seems to be breeding a level of acrimony
that is extremely unhealthy.
And even yourself who is so studied in all of this,
find yourself getting into spats with people online.
Increasingly.
And I follow you on Twitter and I see the engagements
that you have.
And I know that you're very aware of kind of the dynamics
that are playing out right now.
I am very aware and what's crazy is like I'm getting
in spats with my friends, like people that my colleagues,
people I've long known and published with.
They've gotten a really big presence and I'll disagree
with something and then now it all
of a sudden becomes a war.
Like why is disagreement a war all of a sudden.
And a big part of it is in-group disagreeing.
If you just disagree a little bit
or you critique something from your in-group,
you're somehow appear you come across as disloyal
to your in-group.
Right.
Which I don't view that way at all.
It's like, oh, we're just having a conversation.
I mean do you think you're perfect?
Like, I don't think I'm perfect. Like feel free to like,
criticize something I do,
but there's such an us-versus-them mentality that is driving
this psychologically of course,
tribalism is nothing new, right?
It's not in the human species, it's deeply ingrained
and you can explain it evolutionarily when you go all
the way back in small bands,
we had to have a very trouble mindset to survive, right.
But that tribal, that same tribal mindset to survive
it's not necessary to, what's the word that's used a lot
now (indistinct) destroyed.
Everyone's trying to destroy each other,
but we're not trying to learn from each other.
To tie it back to Maslow, I feel like identification
with certain groups online has almost superseded
the importance of our connection to groups
in the analog world. Right?
So the messaging that occurs on places like Twitter is all
about placement or kind of where you sit with respect
to your identification with a certain group,
which makes the whole thing very treacherous, right.
And I think drives that binary nature of it.
Like, are you a member of this group or are you not?
And before you say that,
you better think about how this might reflect upon whether
you're a member in good standing of community X.
That's right.
The system is so insensitive structure,
everything is so guided towards taking a side
and being transparently in a particular identity
or a particular ideology that people like me
and there are others.
I don't think I'm the only one,
but we're trying so hard to be integrative and nuanced.
And there's no reward structure for that right now.
Now, well, first of all, you need like a 20-tweet thread.
Yes.
To even begin to broach any kind of nuanced take
on anything and the incentive structures are such
that it doesn't reward that.
It rewards the hot take.
That's right.
The tweet that's gonna travel, the outrageous perspective
and the click bait title.
That's right.
And it's all being driven by audience capture,
which further calcifies these respective camps and drives us
apart and psychologically like this is not good for us.
It's not good for humanity.
No.
And it's causing some pretty severe, real world problems.
And there are good actors,
but there's a lot of bad actors out there right now,
smart people that I think
are behaving incredibly irresponsibly.
I agree. I absolutely agree.
The big one right now that makes my head explode.
Does the woke/anti-woke cultural war?
if I didn't know if you want a name or something.
Like wokism caused Putin to invade Ukraine,
I mean, it's insane.
Yeah. Yeah. And, but then like there's
this whole anti-woke crowd that,
and the thing is they make some legitimate criticisms
but legitimate criticism, it shouldn't be like.
I think there's a healthy again,
I'm gonna just be on brand here 'cause I'm talking
about healthy versus unhealthy motivations.
I wish there was more healthy criticism in a way
that caused groups to talk to each other. Right.
Like I think there's a lot of on the so-called woke side.
There's a lot of people who feel in their lives,
they are experiencing a lot of racial discrimination, right?
Like see it from their perspective,
like their own personal life.
They are experiencing day in and day out a lot
of discrimination that is really dehumanizing and inhibiting
their own self-actualization.
You have people on other side, they're like,
why are those people always complaining about race?
I don't see race at all. I'm race blind.
Why can't they just shut up about race all the time?
Why does everything have to be about race?
Okay, look, maybe there's some valid critique on this side
that like, okay, we shouldn't view everything
through the lens of race, but there should also be
a compassionate and a extending of graciousness
to at least acknowledge that yes,
while your whole personal life doesn't survive around race,
race doesn't play a big issue in your own life.
There are people in their lives for which race does,
their race does play a role in how people treat them in
their own daily lives.
So I would like to see more an extending of graciousness
on both sides. Does that make sense?
Yeah. A hundred percent.
I mean, compassion.
Compassion.
Empathy, like basic.
But in a way that like allows them to talk,
'cause right now there, there are people
that are just not talking to each other whatsoever. Right.
And there are like some valid critiques on all sides.
I mean, it seems mind boggling to think,
could we ever get people together to actually just listen
to each other on both of these sides of the cultural world?
I should be like okay, well, fair enough.
But I'm just gonna give little critique here.
And then for the other person to be like, you're right.
Maybe I have been a little too race obsessed
because I haven't thought about your point of view.
The other person says, you know what actually,
I can see how, because I'm white I actually don't have any
of these issues that you actually legitimately probably
do have, that's a fair point.
But the thing is they're not mature.
I'm not (crosstalk)
It seems super basic, but the way you describe it feels
like it's a "South Park" episode,
not something that would never happen.
Yeah, I know, it would be a parody.
Right. I think behind it, is this growing distrust
of institutions and there's good reasons for that, right?
Like there's a breakdown in our trust, in government,
in politics and the way that the media communicates with us
and we can have arguments about the validity
or lack thereof of all of that.
But I think that's a real thing.
And I think behind the scenes,
that's a real driver of like "heterodoxy", right.
Which has become this big thing of having a contrary take
on everything and packed into that is this idea that I think
is misplaced which is that the heterodox take
is always the right one.
And it's this purview of the free thinking rebel
who's wailing against censorship versus those who side
with the more conventional take that's supported
by the "experts" who are then maligned as (indistinct)
who are being duped by
the previously mentioned corrupt institutions.
I completely agree.
That are helping on controlling your mind.
I like to think I'm just a free thinker.
I'm not a free thinking rebel.
The second you put in rebel,
then that puts too much pressure in yourself.
Now that means every single thing,
like you free think something, but if,
what if it's not rebellious? What if you like.
The only take that travels online is the heterodox take.
Correct.
And with that, there's this belief that the heterodox take
is always correct.
And in fact, sometimes it is, but most of the time,
it's not.
Sometimes it's not.
Because there's all these people behind the scenes
who are working really hard on these problems
who are not going on podcasts and are not on Twitter
who actually study, subject X for a living
and have a pretty good take on it.
And chances are, they're probably more trustworthy
than Pontificator Y over here, who's got a big following
on Twitter, but is just basically a bloviating mouthpiece.
Yeah. Sometimes the truth is boring, right?
And like, if you're a true free thinker,
if you're like a true free thinker,
you sign me up and you're all in to be a free thinker,
you have to say boring things sometimes.
Like if you're a real truth seeker as well,
that's not just free thinker, but truth seeker,
you'll be balanced, you'll say like,
okay, well that, that's true on that side.
And that's true too. You're looking for the truth.
You're not looking for the fight.
Your ego is not tied up in a particular position.
Yeah. Which puts me in a tough position sometimes,
Rich Roll because sometimes like I say something
that doesn't please anyone,
no side gets what they wanna hear from what I said.
And so it's like, fuck you Scott.
It's like, well no, are we all in this for the truth?
Or are we all in this to fight?
And I think that reveals biases sometimes.
Yeah. Well it reveals who's a good faith actor
and who's acting in bad faith.
That's true.
But from a psychological perspective and trying
to understand this, I feel like there is
a characterological distinction between certain camps.
Like on the one hand, you have people who are very concerned
about freedom and liberty and the kind
of more libertarian perspective and that's really like
a prime driver and focus for those people.
And on the other hand, you have people who are thinking
about collective responsibility and empathy.
And I think.
Yeah.
These are individuals who have just have
very different dispositions and worldviews
and probably are good people in their own rights
or whatever in terms of like how,
they're just wired differently.
And so that's informing a different kind
of siloed perspective.
There's a common humanity there that I'd like to just call
out for a second.
So it's usually the case,
like you care about the vulnerable 'cause the collective one
you mentioned, I would say a lot of that is
about caring for the vulnerable,
caring for those who are marginalized in some way.
You often find you care more about those issues
when you yourself have been marginalized.
I will say those who seem to be on the other side,
the second that they like,
let's say they get canceled and they become marginalized,
suddenly they care about marginalization.
So I would say there's a real common humanity here
to the extent to which if and an issue is not affecting
you personally, you tend to not be as concerned
with that issue.
When I would wanna make the case for living in a civilized,
I would argue a civilized society is one where you care
about real issues that are happening to other people,
even if it's not happening to you personally,
because I would say that like even people on the right,
they get quite angry and they feel like victims,
they can be prone to victimization just as much
as the people on the left when they feel
they've been victimized.
And then suddenly they do care about the vulnerable,
those who have experienced something that they have had,
the definition specifics of the vulnerability differ.
Whereas in the left it may be racism.
It may be other things in the right.
It may be those who have been canceled and they're fighting
for their fellow people who have been canceled,
but still fundamentally,
there's a basic human thing on both sides there,
which is you're fighting for someone who's been wronged
or someone who's been vulnerable in some way.
Once you look beneath the surface there.
Right and you being this bridge between the two,
trying to (indistinct) like I just, I sort of see you doing
that and I don't know how that's going.
I'm trying so hard brother. I'm trying.
How do you see it?
'Cause you actually know a lot of these people.
I do.
Yeah.
I know weird position where I feel
like I am really good friends with people
who wouldn't talk, they themselves wouldn't talk
to each other, but they're friends with me.
You're a safe harbor for.
I'm like a safe space for the right and the left
in a lot of ways.
Yeah. I mean, that's one of my goals actually
is to get people talking to each other
who wouldn't ordinarily talk to each other because
they have a common friend in someone else.
I think we need more of that.
We need more of that, but it's tough.
It is really tough.
There's constant pressures every day
to take a side, constant pressures to take a side in a way
that you alienate the other side.
I'll take a side, I'll take a stand.
I'm not like, I'm not a pushover, sir.
I'm not trying to make the case.
No, I know.
I'm not a pushover.
And I think there's a difference between that.
I will state what I really believe to be true
and I will do so passionately, but often I believe
to be true has nuance.
And that's not what gets rewarded, today.
I will be passionate in saying like, no,
I don't think that's correct.
But the things that I'm pointing out that have the nuance
are not the things that are not the kinds of stances
of what I believe to be true, they get incentivized
very strongly like amongst, there are people out there
though that like nuance and care about that sort of thing.
No, there are.
And we were talking about this before the podcast,
I feel like there's a new ecosystem
that's slowly percolating up.
That is trying to make sense of all of this stuff
and guide well intentioned people in a better way.
But it's a difficult problem and I just see
it metastasizing and it just gets hijacked by
whatever the issue is of the day.
And everybody kind of falls in line and here we are
and this is what we're fighting and yelling about today.
Yeah. I've decided that a much better route for me is
to kind of stay in my lane to a certain degree
because the more that I can help people self-actualize
and teach these principles of self-actualize/transcendence
that are apolitical.
I'm not convinced that getting into the political muck
is really in line with my highest self.
No, I don't think it is.
Yeah. You agree? You agree. Yeah.
And I think about that more and more.
And you don't have to have a take.
That's right. You don't need a take on everything.
I look at it and I'm like, do I need to weigh in on this?
Right, right.
The world will continue to spin
I don't have to participate.
That's right.
And it's just pain when you do anyway.
I feel like I feel a bit cheekiness,
but I also feel real in a lot of my vows and delight
when I get Instagram, like private messages
from people saying, oh, your book really touched me.
It helped me in life.
And then I look at their profiles
like Trump supporter, right?
I'm like, no, that actually makes me feel good that like,
I can get people who are so disparate
who would hate each other,
but I can still reach them in a way that helps them be
a better person in a way that helps them live
a life of meaning.
That makes me feel really good and that's what
really makes me feel most authentic
and alive than getting stuck in this muck.
Yeah. That's something that I wrestle with
because like yourself I wanna cast a wide net,
I'm here to be of service and help as many people
as I'm capable of helping irrespective
of your political affiliation God forbid.
And how does that measure up to the idea that if you have
a platform you have a responsibility to kind
of speak your truth, right?
And that truth might be divisive and alienate certain people
who would otherwise be happy to listen to you or talk
about things that are "more in your lane".
Well, this is another big source of the issue
is that we now treat experts as experts in everything.
Like the Galaxy brand.
By the way, Jordan's a friend/colleague,
but no shade, but you get him on Rogan.
And Rogan's asking him about like climate change.
Well, they're talking about climate change.
That's the Galaxy brand.
I've been celebrated in this one field.
So suddenly I'm a genius about every.
Why would you know everything?
And I don't feel like things used to be that way.
I think something has changed.
Like I remember the days when I would be on podcasts
and they'd ask me about what I know about.
Now people it's like everything, suddenly,
if you're an expert in something, then they're like, oh,
well, what are your thoughts on race relations?
It's like, do I need to be an expert on race relation?
I didn't study that.
Yeah. I think there is some relationship between that
and our dissolving confidence in institutions, right?
Like the idea that, well, the people who are "qualified"
to speak to that have been proven unreliable
or liars or whatever.
So now we have to look to these people
that we deem to be intelligent.
And we grace them with much more leeway and bandwidth
than they're deserving of.
And that cycle creates in their minds the idea that then
therefore they are experts in all those things.
Sure. Yeah. It builds upon itself.
That's the cycle we're seeing.
And then the power, narcissism and all of that starts
to accelerate and that's really, I think what you're seeing
in this secular guru space, right.
Because a lot of these secular gurus,
as you put it will start to think, oh,
maybe I am an expert on COVID vaccines.
No, you still not an expert on COVID vaccines
just because your followers tell you, you are.
Like there's something, it means to be an expert on that.
And you're not it.
Right. Right. The psychology professor who is now
an expert on nutrition.
Right.
I mean, it's crazy, man.
I'm not at my best when I go so out of my lane,
I'm really not at my best because.
And there's a reason for that.
It's because I've put my heart and soul
and studied something that I know pretty well.
And the other things I don't know as well,
like it's not rocket science,
why I'm not at my best when I go outside my lane.
But you understand human behavior.
I do.
And human motivation.
(indistinct)
Which makes it understandable why you
are on Twitter so much.
I'm trying to understand what is going on.
Good luck with that.
What is happening?
This massive human experiment that's being conducted
right now.
What is going on?
Where all these brains are colliding with each other
in ways productive and not so much.
I mean, I can say the most innocuous,
seeming innocuous statement to try to bring love
and joy and peace and all people respond,
stop virtue signaling simp.
I mean, it happened the other day.
And I was like, what is like, I wanna understand this.
I'm not actually hurt by that, I'm more of curious.
Like I wanna understand the psychology of someone
who reads a tweet of something.
That's like, let's just have more like, let's peace,
be like, stop virtue signaling simp.
Like what causes, what is it within you that causes you
to like interpret through that lens?
It's just, isn't that fascinating?
Well, you're the psychologist.
Yeah. Well, it's a deprivation motivation for sure.
But it's one that's becoming increasingly common
on social media where we're now so cynical
that anyone's attempt to improve the world
is some cynical political power move.
And that's what worries me because I see a lot
of genuine attempts.
I mean, I still see the good in people.
I'm sorry like, I don't know why I have to fight.
I have to fight to tell people there's still good in humans.
And that seems like a fight
that I should never have to have.
It's very strange. Yeah.
I don't know, man.
Well, we can't end this podcast on that note, right?
Like let's, let's.
I did say there's good in humans.
Listen, the humans,
I believe in the goodness of humans too,
but there is something about this specific dynamic
that brings the worst out.
Cynicism. Cynicism that none of us have that goodness.
All right. Well, let's switch back to a little bit
of transcendence and self-actualization, (crosstalk) right.
I always try to end these things by putting myself
in the seat of the listener or the viewer or the person
who is perhaps struggling with meeting some
of the baser needs along the hierarchy.
Like I'm just like just trying to be a little bit better.
I'm living an average life. I work a normal job.
I don't have that much free time
or that much expendable income. How can I begin the process
of just trying to ascend this hierarchy a little bit
and build a little bit more meaning and purpose
into my life?
I mean, you referenced earlier in the podcast,
some simple things that can be done to kind of initiate
this process but let's kind of continue on that thought.
Yeah. I mean, I have in the book
a bunch of exercise to help get you more in the be realm
of human existence.
I think that a big part of it is becoming aware of when you
are becoming deficiency motivated
and really become self-aware of that and seeing
how it really feels in your body and realigning yourself
with constantly choosing the growth option,
constantly aligning yourself with your values,
but also seeking out beauty more in your life,
seeking out people that are beautiful.
I'm not just talking physical beauty.
There are people who are beautiful,
surround yourself with those people.
There are so much muck and ugliness on Twitter.
There's so much they could start to make you think
as though that's all there is to the world.
So I think a lot of it is really your attention.
Where do you put your attention,
where you put your attention is where you put your life.
And I think that so much derives from
that knowledge of that fact.
Some of the greatest lessons I learned from
these mindfulness gurus, like people, friends I have who
like are expert meditators,
is that you can have the pain,
you can have this thing that annoys you
and if you're focused on it or annoy you
and just annoy you so much,
but if your attention is just focused on the good
and the beauty in the world, you start to just like forget
these other things exist to a certain extent.
Now it's also true that if you have pain,
the more you focus just on the pain,
the more it subsides as well so this stuff is nuanced,
but I will say that, I just want us to not forget
that there is a higher nature to humans and this is
where Maslow really wanted to go with all,
I read his unpublished essays.
Right, his work was not done, right?
And a big part of the book is you extrapolating
on where he was heading and trying to reinterpret
and reimagine where that might land.
Yeah. And a big part of it was that there is an innate,
intrinsic, higher nature to humans that is just as real
as our lower nature, but it takes more work to transcend
all of the forces, internal and external that
are really keeping us away from being able to see it.
But there are things we can do.
There really are.
And I think it really is about simple choices
that you start to make.
And there's a momentum that takes place over time
when you begin to practice those things
with some regularity.
I'll tell you one thing when a surprising intervention
in clinical psychology for someone who is feeling depressed,
someone who is feeling, they're saying,
I always have these obsessive ruminations over and over
again, help me.
Here's the hack for that,
stop thinking about yourself so much.
Oh, come on, easier said than done.
Well, but one of the interventions
that has been scientific studied
is something called moral elevation.
So this is a concept
that my colleague Jonathan (indistinct) studied,
moral elevation.
So research shows that a better way to help people
with these kinds of issues than to keep obsessively talking
about these issues and to talk about their feelings
and how they always feel negative emotions is to get them
in touch with role models with examples of moral humans
that are doing incredibly inspiring things
that can elevate your whole emotional system.
Yeah.
So, there really is something to helping people
get more into transcendent states of being,
getting you outside of yourselves and to not be so neurotic
because neurotic is a form of narcissism.
Yeah.
You're so self-focused and some of the best ways
of overcoming this is just shifting your attention
outside of yourself.
Yeah. In 12-step, the sort of simple tool for are getting
out of your self-obsession is
to immediately go help somebody else who needs help.
There you go.
Like pick up the phone and just call somebody.
They got it all right, didn't they?
We don't even need psychology.
It's divinely inspired. It's an incredibly profound text
and rule book for living that feels so ahead of its time
in certain ways.
Yeah. So true when I'm around someone
who's a morally elevating individual.
I just like forget about a lot of my problems.
I'm just like, how do I be more of that guy
or girl or woman, whatever your gender is,
how can I be more of that?
Yeah. But another person who's perhaps struggling
a little bit more, might look at that person
and just be resentful and angry.
And that happens to me sometimes.
I mean, like I said, I get these comments.
You never would expect such a comment, right?
Like you write something positive, inspirational
and go the fuck off idiot.
Well, because being earnest is somehow a threat.
Yeah. I haven't really fully figured that one out.
Like, what is it that is a threat?
Like, what is it the threat to people
when you are being positive or when you're trying to.
You're a weak beta.
It's a sort of a beta thing.
So strength is this sort of notion of masculinity
as not showing empathy or not showing emotion.
How can we make compassion, cool?
Like, I almost wanna say again,
but I don't think it's ever been really cool,
but how can we make compassion just as cool as like standing
up and owning someone.
I'm trying to do that.
I think the way that you do it is you model it in
an aspirational way and you find a way to channel it
through a certain type of masculinity that's attractive
to that wayward young man, who's looking for a mentor
or some kind of guidance.
Yeah.
But you do it without the toxic aspects
of what it means to be masculine. Right.
So that's why I think athletes hold a special place
in the public discourse because for a certain type
of young man, like that type
of physical prowess means something.
It's demonstrative in an active way.
And I think it's incumbent upon athletes to understand that
and take responsibility for that in a way
that can be positively impactful for younger people
who are looking up to them.
It's an opportunity to model masculinity in a way
that provides space for compassion and empathy.
And I do it through veganism is a good way of doing it.
Like if I can be fit and physically active,
but also be like a voice for the animals.
Yeah.
Which is considered to be kind of a beta thing, right.
But recast it.
Why would that be bad?
I mean, do we have three hours to talk about that?
Like I mean, I wrote an article.
The role of masculinity and food choice is like
a whole strange psychological sticky wicket.
It's like paleo is like manly.
Yeah. It appeals to a certain type of person who's looking
for an identity like the role of identity
in the nutrition world is like a super interesting thing.
Yeah. I know that that is a topic for another day,
but I wrote an article called "Myth of the alpha male",
because I think that young men who are trying to figure out
how to have more women in their, women in their life,
they need to look more long in the lines
of what the science says about what women actually want.
Not what men think women want.
Imagine that.
Because men have it wrong.
Let's start there.
Men actually have it wrong.
A real man to a woman it tends to be a little bit different
than what a real man is when it turns to male
to male competition.
Right like what a man would think a real man would be
to a woman versus what a woman is actually looking for.
And what a woman really considers a real man.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, I feel like those normative definitions
are influx right now.
That's true.
In a positive way.
I don't know. What do I know?
Not much, Scott, not as much as you.
That's definitely not true.
Depends on the topic. Depends on the topic.
Cool man. Well, I think we did it.
How do you feel?
I feel, my butt feels good.
You feel good? You like that chair better?
I like this chair much better. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I feel very good.
Did we cover all the stuff?
We covered a lot of good ground,
but like let's keep up the conversation.
Yeah. I'd like to have you back. (crosstalk)
Yeah. We can pull on, we can pull on some more threads.
We're similar spaces and I really like your way
of being a lot.
Thank you. Appreciate that. Likewise.
If people want to learn more about you, of course,
please pick up Scott's latest book, "Transcend the new sign
of self-actualization" which you can find on his website,
which I'll link up in the show notes or on Amazon
or wherever you buy books.
Also tell me a little bit about this new,
I mean, you move from the east coast.
You're no longer captured by the Ivy league institutions.
No.
You're free on the left coast
to fly a free flag (crosstalk).
And you've got this, like you open up this institute, right?
Yeah. I started
the Center for the Science of Human Potential
and we do courses like we did,
we're doing an eight-week transcend course to help people,
we're working on all sorts of collaborations
and working on collaboration with The Second City improved
to do like improv for self-actualization.
I'm working on
a self-actualization coaching certification program
that can be used in different sectors of society,
including education.
I'd love for teachers to start to rethink their role
in the classroom or as self-actualization coaches.
Yeah, I really feel like I'm living my values,
the things I wanna do to help people realize
their potential and I get to like do a lot of edibles
on the beach, so that's good.
Am I allowed to say that?
Good for you.
Hey listen, I would if I could, I'll just leave it at that.
Awesome. Well, let's do this again sometime soon.
You can learn more about Scott
at what's your website, Scott Barry Kaufman.
Here I have (indistinct).
scottbarrykaufman.com.
But I have a book coming out this year called,
"Choose Growth" that I think it'll help a lot of people.
It's the workbook companion to "Transcend".
"Transcend" was published during the start
of a global pandemic.
Yeah.
Would not wish that anyone publishing a book,
this one was a little more forethought planning.
We actually have a book that can help people grow
from the pandemic itself.
So what I did is I used the situation and I made lemon
out of lemonade, right.
I published a book that like, of course,
no one read because it came out
the day the pandemic started.
So brutal.
And I used it as a way of like, you know what,
I'm gonna work next couple years on a book
that I'm gonna get ahead of this.
I'm gonna get ahead of this and really help people,
specifically who had some sort of setback
during the pandemic as I did with this with lots of things.
And we all had.
So I think we can really grow.
So yeah, it's called "Choose Growth".
Cool, man. When's that coming out?
That's coming out September of this year.
I co-wrote it with Jordan Finegold,
who's the founder of a field called positive medicine.
And she was also a former undergraduate student
of mine at Penn.
She came into my office as an undergrad telling me
that she wants to go to med school
and loves positive psychology.
And I was like, you should start a field positive medicine.
And she's like, really?
I was like, yeah, here we are almost 10 years later,
she has her MD and she the leader of the field
of positive medicine, couldn't be more proud of her.
So we teamed up on this book to really figure out
how we can help people.
Not just body, not just mind, but body as well.
Yeah. Cool man.
Well, when that comes out,
come back and we can talk about that.
Thank you.
All right, man.
Peace.
(bright music)